This is episode 500 of the,
you know my name,
podcast 500 can't say my name anymore.
I've decided that it's very dueschy.
If you say your own name
as much as you possibly can avoid,
this episode is brought to you by legal zoom.
Any legal troubles,
Tom,
who wrote that lately?
Doug's 10 hope not have legal troubles like say if you want.
Well,
here's the best use of it.
Not Troubles,
but issues like incorporation you can incorporate with legal zoom.
Did you know that?
Yes,
I know that.
Did you know you can do it cheap?
You could form an LLC for just under 99 bucks or just 99 bucks and up before I
fuck a girl on the road,
I have paperwork that's printed off from legal zoom.com saying that she is
consenting to be here.
You're going gonna need that someday.
We're going to need videotape confessions.
It's very important.
So does legals and taking that first step option.
Maybe we can ask him.
You know what?
I think it's,
I think it's a project.
They're working on it.
It's in moe cane in there.
What are you doing?
Cause it just said you.
What are you searching for?
And just what's Mccain,
mushrooms and cocaine.
Oh,
do you think the legal zoom knows about that?
They say don't put that in the commercial.
They're not actual legal representatives,
but they do provide a fantastic service so you can be your own legal
representative.
Douglas.
Dan Hope such a good pitch man.
On top of that,
you would probably the best ever.
And uh,
on top of that,
they can connect you to an attorney if you panic a third party attorney.
So if the shit hits the fan,
you're feeling out the legal zoom paperwork and you're like,
you know what?
I feel very Jaylee.
I feel like I'm going to jail.
I'm feeling kind.
You can call that emergency number from legal zoom.
They'll look out that window,
read a billboard and send you to some solid good breaking ball.
The fucker.
No,
there won't be that solid Goodman did a hell of a job in that goddamn attorney.
Anyway,
this month,
legal zoom,
this is the part that I'm supposed to read this month.
Legal Zoom celebrates innovation by helping you launch your dream.
How do you do that?
Legal Zoom.
Maternity is my favorite.
What about you Tom?
Oh,
fraternity lawsuits.
You ever been a kid isn't in a paternity suit?
No,
I haven't.
I was about 10 years ago.
It was frightening.
Boof.
That's rough.
If we have time to the story,
we still will come right after the commercial.
I want to hear it.
I want to hear you.
Let's see.
Got a bump me out,
man.
Okay.
Anyway,
go to legal zoom.com please so I can stop and a user,
Bro.
Use the referral code.
Rogan at checkout to save some money.
Celebrate innovation with legal zoom through the end of June and get a special
price on trademark copyright or provincial patent applications by using the
referral code.
Rogan at checkout.
Do it.
Doug.
Stan hope you know you want to.
Hey,
you know that collection of fucking Chewbacca is and other star wars
memorabilia.
That's your only valuables.
Who's going to get that if you,
okay.
Were you hanging out with us?
We're also brought talking to the listeners.
Yeah,
they,
I don't think there's a lot of dudes out.
Your stepmother getting those collectibles.
Go to legal zoom.
Get a will.
What if they're signed?
Who's who is Chewbacca?
Everybody knows who Han Solo was.
You know?
Everybody knows it's hair.
Oh,
I haven't been the death pool.
Stand up celebrity death pool.
Hey,
I get a plug.
Yeah,
please.
Actual like seven foot dude that's aging now and I was going to take him on my
death pool and then Joe be the guy who runs it,
said I already got him.
Oh,
he did some in Saturday.
I can't all have the same guys.
They're like,
Great Danes.
Seven foot guys at 60 years old.
No,
no,
you're not around for long.
But somebody asked that to wilt Chamberlain.
He went up to wilt Chamberlain.
It was having a conversation with them.
It's like,
you know guys that are,
this is talls you.
They don't really live forever and apparently well chamber,
it was like,
hey man,
fuck you.
Was it stuttering John?
I don't know who it was,
but it was rude and true.
Apparently tarred,
pump all that blood up into that ticker.
Seven foot tall dude,
five seven foot tall.
I'd be in bed right now.
Does it by my legs,
over my heart.
This is a reverse work.
If you're like a small person,
do you live longer?
No,
no.
They tie quick too.
I went a lot of Guinness Book and my last death pool picks what's,
what are you changing?
Budgets will make it to a hundred and that would be like what's like the good
like size to live long.
It's like five four,
five.
What's the world average is right.
The Chinese tend to live a long time.
I know Brian by fucking filthy Scotsman manager is chomping at the bit because
he knows all these dumb facts,
but he said Mediterranean people tend to live the longest,
but I would say that diet thing though,
right?
That Asians and also like fish,
they get around a lot of other nice people.
They have these villages,
they all know each other's the level of love that apparently actually extends
lifespan,
less stress,
a lot less trust.
Very be like Doug.
Stan hope a lot of things that they don't account for when they just generalize
people.
Exactly.
They say Asians don't get a lot of lung cancer,
but they have no dairy in their diet,
so they take those two things and you go,
oh,
I love that.
I go,
well,
I won't drink milk and eat cheese and I'll just keep chain smoking and I'll be
Japanese forever.
I don't know what you're talking about,
but we're also brought to you by tank and if you go to rogan.ting.com you can
save yourself some money and some excellent cell phone service ducks.
Dan Hope these 10 uses the sprint backbone,
which means that this,
these sounds so goofy when you're doing them in the middle.
We should have when you have to look at your friends when you're doing
[inaudible] frankly and roller.
I'm Russell while he does the commercial,
I'm not embarrassed to do it.
God damn commercial hub,
dare you.
Hey,
the only way,
the only way you get paid is if someone does.
You do a commercial.
They have that new a galaxy s five on there though with the thumbprint scanner
and all that heart rate monitor that you can do that on an iPhone too.
I just found out that a lot,
actually,
you do that in almost any phone that has a camera.
They have these applications.
Read a,
it reads the flash.
Jamie showed it to me.
It reads the flash from the phone,
apparently lights up your thumb and through that the camera can see the actual
blood pumping in your finger and so that's how it reads your,
your actual heartbeat from an application on regular phone.
I don't want to stay alive to see what Shit is like in 20 years.
If the technology is so incredible now,
what's it going to be like in 20 years later?
My cigarettes?
I don't know.
How accurate is that you got,
I'm like,
is they're super accurate?
Yeah,
it's dead on.
I've,
I've tried it with that in a heart rate monitor at the same time.
It's dead on.
It's crazy.
You know what I've heard about ting?
Is there fantastic.
Oh,
you haven't heard that?
I don't bullshit people.
Doug Stanhope trending on Twitter.
What Tim does is they rent time on the sprint backbone,
but they do it in a way where you can cancel anytime you want.
You own your phone Sunday bullshit where you have to pay them back 300 bucks
because college financing,
no contract fucking scamp biggest scam in the world.
Not only that,
no early termination fees,
which is another big scam.
Here's another scam.
The actual minutes,
when they charge you x minutes,
you get 50 minutes per month and you know this amount of data.
The reality is a lot of times you pay for way more than you're using.
You're not using a lot of your minutes with Ting.
You only pay for what you use.
It really is a great way to do it.
Like you don't have to,
like you don't have a,
you know,
$250 a month bill or whatever the fuck it is.
It's like if you were out of the country,
if you are only making a few calls in a week,
if you say,
you know what,
I'm not even fucking texting people anymore.
You Shit will drop down to nothing.
10 is like a good bookie.
He said it's 20 bucks.
Just let it ride.
Well they know well everybody,
you need your phone,
Doug.
Stan,
hope you can.
You could live out in the middle of nowhere,
but you're going to have a fucking phone on you and even you switched over to a
smartphone.
Publish Pastor.
Yes I did.
Do you hung into that flip phone?
I get turned down at Uber but Uber doesn't work right,
so it's not me.
Brian put Uber on my phone and he goes,
no,
I'll put it on your phone cause he does.
Is it cheap?
Fuck.
That's a good insight.
God is Jackson,
but it doesn't wizard with that accident.
Perfect.
Brian.
Brian Hennigan doesn't even have a proper Scottish accent.
What's it doing Doug?
He talks like it doesn't tell.
It does.
It tells me I'm somewhere else.
Yeah,
I can show me.
I was in fucking north Hollywood when I was in West Hollywood.
I can fish out.
You have to fix that for you.
Yeah,
there's probably something wrong with you.
You probably look,
we're hiding some shit from the government so it doesn't know exactly where you
are.
That's what it is like you hide some of those location services because you
worried they're going to fucking close in on you.
Like the physical department.
Yeah.
Living off the grid is as easy as not knowing how to use your fucking self.
It really is.
It's go bust.
This guy,
he's in north Hollywood.
No,
I'm not.
I just don't know how to use Uber.
Yeah,
go to [inaudible] Dot [inaudible] Dot Com and save 25 bucks.
I love Tang rogan.ting.com.
All right.
We don't need any more commercials.
Get the cell phone they used in space.
No,
they didn't hang.
Sorry.
Oh,
you funny.
But we're good
experience.
Try by day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
All Day.
Not to be confused with Tang Tang.
Remember when we were a kid was that was hard.
Big thing partnered up.
Dang.
You could sip this delicious juice while you know you're a cop.
Doubles as a phone your tank up,
your pimp style tank,
cups or rhinestones around him.
Remember when we were kids.
Tang was like the big thing.
Yeah,
it came from the space program.
They go,
oh look,
it made it good.
Ting was fucking terrible dog shit.
Fake orange shoes,
Mre.
Is this a great dinner?
That was one of the first commercial.
That was one of the first product placement things that Tang people.
Totally,
I mean that wasn't good for people.
It's ridiculous.
And they sold that is like the astronaut drinks.
So like attrition,
you know,
generations of Americans dreads a shit.
Homemade Gatorade down shitty gate.
The electrolytes.
Yeah.
Tags.
I'm going to be an astronaut is still around this tank still around.
I'm sure.
Yeah,
that's fine.
Off tank still around.
You know if poor people somewhere drinking it,
they're so unimpressed.
If you know,
if Tang was like,
yeah,
this astronaut program,
they're like pitch,
what'd you Astros now?
Right.
It's like youtube comments like where's your astronauts?
Who's going to the moon?
Yeah.
The last famous astronaut was a stocker racing from Florida to use them to stab
a lover or something.
Well I've been doing a bit there in a diaper.
She was wearing a diaper so she didn't have to stop and go learn that trick.
She drove the entire time and she shit herself.
She was an astronaut.
She was crazy.
Oh yeah.
Bitch was crazy.
Tang.
The drink,
it seems like it's still around.
Hmm.
Most of that shit.
If you look it up,
you can buy it if it,
if you can't find it in a store,
you can find it online.
Quispe Cereal and
candy.
Okay.
Talking about marathon bars,
that was an original Tang Tang is sold in both powdered and ready to drink for
him.
Oh,
new Tang is where they jumped the shark.
They say if you could find the original tank now,
yeah.
You could actually buy like a sugar free version of tank containing aspartame.
Wow.
Hmm.
Oh,
let's put more cancer in your diabetes.
Hey listen,
Doug Stanhope,
there's 10% of the RDA of vitamin A,
calcium and vitamin E and riboflavin,
10% 10% so 10 glasses at Tang and you're covered.
That's almost half what cocoa puffs has.
It's um,
it's got 100% of your vitamin C.
Oh,
that's actually pretty good.
I 100% of your vitamin C is not that much though.
The people that think you should take vitamin C thank you.
Should take a look.
A good amount of it like take that shit all the time.
But Doug Stanhope you just take cigarettes and you're fine.
I this week I've been bad but I had quit a lot.
He quit a lot.
You held it back.
Have you ever tried the electronic route?
Yeah,
we've talked about this.
Yeah.
Red Band said he was coughing up blood.
They're there.
There are a lot better now.
Like the newer ones aren't.
They're terrible cause I just got quit a month ago and I made it two weeks and I
tried like four different brands and I was sucking on them constantly and I was
off to six for a couple of weeks but my lungs were killing me at one point and
then it comes a point where you're like well fuck,
give me a cigarette cause you're just getting like blast and blast of nicotine
like more nicotine than you would be getting from just having a cigarette.
I did great when I was at home alone,
I had like six weeks off and I mean there's full weeks.
I didn't smoke and then sometimes someone would show up at my house that smokes
and I'd steal a cigarette.
So I'd smoke a couple and then six weeks of 95% quit smoking went on the road.
And I'm like,
all right,
now I'm just going to bump them from the fucking opening acts,
find outside smoking.
I sent Bingo out to go get me a couple of cigarettes before the show and this
week it's just after the fucking first night of party and we were talking about
I'm buying packs bucket.
But once you say fuck it,
and that's the,
the problem with being a comic is you're inclined to say fuck it more often than
not because it seems like the comic choice,
you know,
and you're in that situation,
you're like,
come on.
What's that?
The show must go on.
I think there's a point that I made it,
I quit a month ago and I made it two weeks and I wasn't working and it was once
I went back and I did shows in Atlanta and I was bumming them off to staff.
And then I was in Minneapolis the next weekend after that and like snuck a pack
and then just said fuck it.
I mean I think cause I,
cause I,
cause I was doing shows and that's my rhythm and having a cig and get on stage.
I don't want to influence the kids.
Ah,
but like before and after
and that was a thing where at the comedy store it was a big deal because guys
would smoke on stage and the audience members couldn't smoke
cause there was a provisional,
right?
Yeah.
As a part of the performance you're allowed to smoke.
But uh,
I think they dropped that.
I don't think they allow a lot of places.
I remember cause I would,
I,
I did that the uh,
immediately I was doing that when they passed it in California.
Once I found out about that law and I was doing it in Minneapolis and then a bar
started doing that as a night where a smoker's could be on stage.
And so that place is just all spoken.
But you had to have everyone thought of the performance so far into their face
that they changed the law.
And I think most places have changed the law.
Yeah,
that sucks.
They fucked it up.
Remember when we started the clubs where everyone smoked and the in the 80s and
I didn't mind back then.
I loved it and I smoke with dancing.
The spotlight.
You're on stage.
It was sexy.
It was like filming a war movie.
Got It man.
And pool halls as well.
I don't like it.
I don't like cigarettes.
I think they're disgusting and it scares me when I see my friends smoke cause I
know you're going to die ugly.
I know you're going to die ugly.
And I loved it.
I tell this guy all the time,
I love him,
but he smokes and when I see him smoke I get scared.
I get scared that you're,
you're locked up in a wrestling match with a dragon.
It's a dark demon.
It's gonna slowly rot you out from the insides and it tricks you into doing it.
It sucks you into its web with habit and novelty.
And the idea that it lets,
it's beautiful,
the fucking smoke and so good.
I know that's one thing.
And then the other thing is,
becomes part of your body.
It becomes a part of you.
You,
you need it.
It becomes your system.
Your,
your body gets integrated into accepting this.
I feel like I got my appointment.
I don't know.
Some of that having a pack of cigarettes and a lighter on me,
you know?
Well listen,
I'm not judging.
You know,
I have friends that
telling them you're secure.
You know,
I got what I need,
retirement.
Fuck that.
I got a carton and I'm a hypocrite
smoking weed.
And I don't think smoking weed is bad for you.
It's certainly not bad for you in the same way.
And I did not.
Once the cigarette companies get ahold of it either way,
I don't think it's the best thing for you.
This is it.
The best thing in the world for you to smoke a plant,
you know,
it's like,
I thought you went straight to vaporizer and edibles.
Those two.
Yeah.
I just watched you smoke,
so no,
no,
I do that too.
Oh yeah.
But I'm,
I'm hypocritical in that sense of cause like smoking,
it's not good.
It's not good to smoke something,
you know,
anything.
We like Diaz,
I'm like,
stop smoking.
He only eats it and use a vaporizer because he said he's,
he's long started feeling way better once he did that.
But I believe it.
And the animal law edibles as someone who doesn't live in California,
the edibles here are ridiculous.
You got every candy,
Jolly Rancher,
candy.
We'd uh,
you know,
a York peppermint patties.
Anything you can think of,
they've duplicated exactly like a candy or,
well,
there's a bit of an issue.
There is a little bit of an issue with it.
It's beautiful that exists.
And I'm a complete libertarian and the idea that you should be able to,
you almost let your filter.
Yeah,
but this place is,
the weed culture in California is so more evolved in Amsterdam.
Well it's,
they're so powerful that it's really like an intense psychedelic.
If you eat one of these pot brownies or these Chuba choose Chiba Chews,
they have these Chiba chews that are like seven.
How many,
what's the milligrams?
Uh,
take one fourth.
If you don't want to die as they are insane.
If you tank the whole,
it's one candy.
And if you take that one candy,
you will reexperience here.
Higher life from,
from the moment you,
you,
you were up an egg in the comm,
washed over you and turned you into two eggs and you are cell started dividing.
That's the right looking for these candies.
Could you take,
say,
one of these candies.
Say you already have a preexisting condition,
a mental illness saying,
and say you're at a rock star's house trying to get a podcast and you're doing
incredible amounts of blow and you go home with a little bit of that blow and
then you do the rest of that blow while your boyfriend sleeping,
preparing for the bill burp podcast.
And you also eat an edible while you have a preexisting condition.
Could you spiral into such a catatonic state that the landlord from the air B
and B,
that you're staying in comes in to talk to you and you won't respond to them.
So your boyfriend and your tour manager have to put you in bed where you piss
the bed in your first Ab Airbnb and it takes you 24 hours to come out and said,
Ken atonic state.
Uh,
if I had to guess,
I could say that hypothetically,
did Marilyn Manson give you a gift bag when you left and edibles?
It wasn't me,
wasn't me.
Skin moisturizer wasn't me.
You gotta be careful with that shit.
I had to check her text messages and it said,
well,
Hey,
we're uh,
we'll be there on time.
I just stand up sleeping and I just ate a pod candy and then I see an empty
Baggie and I'm like,
you did all that and now
they can get you,
they can get you and take you on a ride that you're just not,
you're not going to be capable of going out just doing things,
going to the airport,
getting your clothes on.
You're not going to be capable.
And that's the gist.
You could buy it at any store.
Go buy one of these cupcakes by one of these rocket cookies.
Take cookie and go right to the center of the fucking universe.
I mean,
they're intense psychedelics.
We've talked about it before,
but the,
the chemical processes when you,
wait,
is this a,
is this ground already worked over on the Joe Rogan experience?
I've cookies.
We've talked about it a few times.
I know it sounds crazy.
It seems so novel.
I was at Dick Clubs in La at home or gone back to go back to ting.
If you eat that shit,
it's,
it'll,
it'll hurt you.
It'll hurt you.
You gotta be real careful.
I've seen comedians all over la with those little pen.
Does your fries are things different?
That's not an eating it when you eating it
all the different varieties.
I always assumed those were ecigarettes that everyone has.
There's a lot of those are little weed vaporizer.
Oh whoa.
Like a motherfucker.
They do hit like a motherfucker,
but there's both.
That's why I think it's a product I want to endorse.
That should be their slogan hits like a motherfucker.
I don't think that's a good move.
If I read hits like a motherfucker be like,
who is the guy that's making this?
That's all he could come
in podcasting.
You could probably get copy like that all you have to be like your mother
fucker,
the balls like a motherfucker.
You should buy this.
This will take you on a ride to the center of the universe.
My man,
my man would be highlighted,
you know,
feel free to use your own colloquialism.
It's,
it's funny when you were about to start red band said,
okay,
uh,
we're alive and you go,
Oh shit,
we're live.
Oh,
don't say anything that you were making a joke like,
oh,
don't say anything.
We're live.
It's opposite.
Yesterday I had fell in love with a man fucking Bert Kreischer.
He's a great man.
I fucking like,
I clicked with him so quickly.
I'll get some,
let me met him.
No,
I've met him before but we never really hung.
Oh,
he's the best.
He's a sweetie and I knew that.
Yeah,
he's just walking.
Wicked man crush right away.
His house is just like my house down to the,
I walked in,
I knew exactly where his booze stash was.
I'm like,
I'm just going to make a drink.
Anyway.
Fucking fell in love with a guy by the sweetie.
We had to,
we had to pause and go to break where we talk about like shit that and then we'd
come back on the air and like certain stuff,
you can't take trash talking.
Other comics come back on the air.
Well,
he's on the travel channel two and the travel channel is owned by some religious
folks.
Oh yeah.
Not like that,
but,
but that is a problem.
But he's got to be real careful about what he does.
Or I'm trying to make a drink.
He doesn't smoke weed,
but if he did,
he wouldn't do it on Ustream.
You know what I'm saying?
Who owns the travel channel is some somebody that loves the baby.
Jesus.
Allegedly.
I might be just talking shit.
I don't know.
I just,
what I've read from Anthony Bordain.
Okay.
Certain conversations I might've had with him.
And what did you ordain on the show?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Wow.
He's a good dude.
His,
you know,
his wife is a,
a Jujitsu fanatic.
That's my end.
That's how I got to Mile Dane
and followed me or retweeted me or something.
And it was a,
I was so starstruck.
Oh,
he's the best.
He's a sweetie.
If you met the guy,
you would love him.
He's just
his show.
Is it,
since he's gone to CNN,
I guess they had,
you know,
a visa access to like his shows just gone to a whole different level.
Now I can mirror and Mar.
Yeah,
we're going to Allen Brian,
by the way.
I got plans and one of the plans is flying to New York to do podcasts with
people that we can't get to fly out here.
So like,
I can't keep asking people to just come out here.
So guys like board day and I'm gonna find out when he's going to be there and
I'll just drive and haven't come under Bisbee I'm going to use,
try to use the serious,
cause we were on serious.
We're not serious.
I don't know if you know that.
I listened to it all the time.
It's the weirdest,
but,
um,
so I'll,
I'll,
I wanted to get like Bordain a few other guys that live there.
I C k.
Yeah.
Well Louise just so fucking busy.
I feel bad asking him yet,
but he's on opie and Anthony all the time,
but that's like,
you know,
when he can in the morning I'll ask him.
But,
um,
I know he's crazy,
but he's the most ridiculously busy person I've ever met.
He's got a,
he does a great bit that I saw that someone made a clip of him talking about it
was,
it's really funny.
It starts him talking about nut allergies and he compares like things that you
know to be true.
But there's always this too,
but maybe like,
it's like,
but I know,
but maybe it's fucking really funny man.
It's really funny.
I hadn't seen one see case bits is new bits off of his new special God damn.
It was good.
It was really funny.
New special not,
yeah,
the new one.
Where's he?
He was in Phoenix and the theater in the round.
It's really,
really good stuff,
man.
It's like you,
you,
you listened to it,
you read it and you watch it rather and you're like,
fuck,
I want to go write something.
Like this is like,
maybe want to go right.
It was good.
Yeah.
You know,
that's the best thing about like I used to always think that about like when
Chappelle would come to the store,
I got always a longer run home and right.
Yeah.
Anything that gives you that,
that little juice like you want to create too.
Cause you know how good it made you feel.
Why?
Like I last time I saw Chappelle at the story,
it was like the height of his popularity before,
uh,
he,
he'd quit the comedy central show and he was just,
he would just show up like maybe like the day before they would schedule this
and it would just be mob and he was in the main room and uh,
he,
it was so funny and so like I hadn't seen him in like six months and it was all
new shit.
It was like 100% new and it's like a new hour and you'll you left,
there you go.
Just go on.
God Damn,
I need to go to work.
Yeah.
I want to go.
He had that gift,
I think,
say it very fucking stupid way.
But he's one of those guys,
he talks funny.
Anyway,
so we already has a leg up.
This is Joey said yes,
you said it best.
The Ds could read the phone book.
Right,
right.
So he has that already but he can write too.
So if it's new shit,
what,
what would you know be filler to him would be a closer to me.
Yeah.
Diaz has,
I mean I don't,
I don't want to give up any of this material,
but he's got this bit about this chick named Lucy snore Bush.
He's told the story about on the podcast,
but now he's turning to a bid in his act,
a true story about him sneaking into her house,
climbing into her window and eating her pussy in the middle of the night and
then escaping.
I don't think I've ever laughed as hard in my life.
We just did Santa Barbara together and W W I was watching him on stage and he's
doing this Lucy snore Bush thing and I'm having a hard time catching my breath,
like are legitimately having a hard time catching my breath.
I see.
So d as in San Francisco and he was doing that bit where he's like,
are you like punches?
Uh,
and the audience is dying in San Francisco.
They're like usually really touchy about like,
what are you going to believe?
What the WIG and a black guy,
there's no support groups where these people,
he's one of the best ever.
He's like as far as like Lisa Snell,
Bush,
Lucy snoring.
What's her name?
Lucy snore Bush.
It was so,
it was,
it was painfully funny.
It's painfully funny.
He's my all time favorite.
Well,
I've ever seen that made me laugh.
The hardest is not a,
not a single person has ever made me laugh harder than Diaz
me and see hurt me and Chrysler.
We're picking our ultimate fo Forman tour with a wildcard fuck up.
He picked,
he picked Diaz.
This is fuck up.
I have to see him.
I Diaz is so good that I started taking two guys on the road with me during the
dark days when Diaz would just go vanish in the middle of the night.
But I,
I,
he was so good that I said,
okay,
I need a backup opener.
So it would bring two openers because there's too many times,
D has just vanished.
He just would disappear.
It just,
you couldn't
call him.
I got booked like that w for auto and George where they wanted a book,
auto and George,
but they needed to co headline himself.
He didn't show up.
There was another x rated act that could fit the fucking marquee.
You got to do that man.
Unfortunately with some guys,
but they're worth it.
And now he's super reliable.
Now he's just say every gig.
He's,
he's there.
Well,
he's just into comedy now.
I think it's just the front for the first time in his life,
he's being recognized for what he does and he's enjoying creating new shit.
He's enjoying being a comic.
Like when I talk to him about it,
he's got a lot of other success.
Like he's always getting called into movies and shit.
And you know,
he did that.
Uh,
I sat,
I sat through the grudge match just because I knew he was in it.
He's having a lot of those that are happening to them.
But the big thing is his stand up man,
his standup,
he's selling out everywhere he deserves and yeah,
he,
fuck,
yeah.
What a difference when the audience already loves you,
when you get there you can win them over different animal.
Dude,
he went on stage and Santa Barbara when we work together and I,
I've taken some of his openings where I introduced them and then I film it like
watching them go on stage.
I put them on youtube cause they're so ridiculous.
He goes on stage and people standing up like bowing to him screaming like 2000
people screaming and bowing to Joey Diaz as so good.
And for a guy like that to finally get that,
you know,
dude,
I,
I always go to see a guy that age.
Yeah,
he deserves how many church he's,
he's an animal dude.
He's an animal.
If I could,
if I could hire a 24 hour nurse to keep them alive,
I would just don't think you would get the fuck out of it.
Listen,
I'm Cuban,
I'm never gonna die.
Get outta here,
bitch.
You kick him out of his house.
You got to like find out like a guy like that.
I get to take care of in a gentle fashion.
You got to figure out how to keep them alive.
But wiki check them.
Yeah.
I'm going to put that pill and a piece of cheese,
find some fucking new drugs and put it in his ice cream to take it and put it in
something,
some new thing.
Regenerative tissue thing of the government and fence.
Just throw it in his food.
Hey,
uh,
Bryan told me the other night you're getting your blood reinjected was that
bullshit?
No,
no,
no.
It's true.
Well,
it's not your blood reinjected it's a,
it's called Regina King.
It was invented by this German guy.
It's,
it's your blood.
They spin it in a centrifuge and they heat it up.
So you take your blood and in this summer we're doing an ad copy again.
No,
Regina chain.
Dot.
There's a guy named doctor Peter Weller,
I believe his name is.
He developed this process for us.
Any Robo cause,
inflammation.
That's the other guy.
You know you might be right.
I might have the wrong guy.
Hold on a second.
That's it.
I'll do the ad while you look it up.
It's like,
are you tired of looking at those center genics guys half naked in a skymall
catalog.
Oh,
does it make your face young to ooze?
Anybody that's in pain,
it can be a tremendous help.
It's the most potent anti inflammatory that I figured out.
Well,
I did it a few times.
It's amazing.
Was all these professional athletes,
inflammatory jug.
It's called alcoholism and it works on my penis.
I don't think it works.
It hasn't been inflamed in years.
I'm sure Peter Welling.
You're right.
It's not.
It's welling.
Robocop.
I said Weller.
No,
no.
What did she say?
Right.
You're right sweetie.
I love you.
You're right.
Always.
I'm blessed.
Refer to you more than I refer to myself.
How about that?
But he was a guy in Germany who figured this shit out.
They take your blood and they,
they heat it and your blood has a reaction while it's still viable.
It has a reaction to the heat as if it's got a fever.
And it creates this intense anti inflammatory response.
So it's in the very blood itself.
They take it out of your body that heated,
they spin it and then it creates this yellow shit and it's yellow shit.
They pull it out and they,
they call it something Regena keen serum,
I don't know the technical and then they squirt it into anywhere you have
arthritis and in where you have uh,
any kind of swelling,
inflammation and it has like a magical response.
That's why all these athletes like um,
it's,
we've got paint manning battened back into football.
He had two neck surgeries and he was fucked and he went to Germany and he got
this procedure done in his neck and it just fixed it.
Shot out.
I was using,
I was talking to Sean Rouse,
I don't know if you knew him.
Yeah.
He has serious arthritis and he wants to talk to you about it because he loved
to talk.
Yes.
I mean if you look at his hands he needs to like break all his hands like good.
It is operations and you know,
no,
he's got some serious right.
Yeah.
Cause he's got the most crippling arthritis,
uh,
which,
I should say because of Sean Rouse,
I saw a young comedian get knocked the fuck out the other night at the comedy
store.
Somebody got knocked out by it.
I was sitting there with a Sha Jason Rouse,
Canadian guy who lived in London and Jj Whitehead,
a Canadian guys at the other end.
And then Sean and he was plastered man,
and who was Sean rouse?
And he's,
yeah,
he's sitting there.
The story is just lost all credibility.
I'm talking to,
there's a guy from Boston,
Mike favor men or whatever,
uh,
this tall young open mic comedian.
We found out he was an open miker later comes up.
I thought he knew Jason had Jay Jay because of the way he's making fun of,
and one guy at Jason's got a lot of tats.
He said,
hey,
always making me stupid tattoo jokes.
And I'm kind of talking to Mike from Boston.
Charlie there.
No,
no,
no.
Uh,
he would surely wasn't a,
he had left,
uh,
earlier,
we heard that Ross was really fucked up,
wrapped Hayley plastered.
So anyway,
this topic,
roads,
bronze medalist and story editing,
this comedian,
the guy,
he turns to Sean very grandly to the table and he goes,
I'm sorry to bother you gentlemen.
I just couldn't pass up the chance to meet Mobi.
And he like sticks his hand out to Sean who's all fucked up and can barely lift
his head.
This kid was a fucking Douche and Mike from Boston's got like to kind of taxi
driver knew Stan Guy Hat on and then the kid grandly turns table of veteran
comedian
sitting here.
Grandly turns to Mike and he goes,
I'll be seeing you in the morning when I come to pick up my newspaper.
Oh,
amen.
You sent it to favor,
favor,
favor men doesn't play.
I turned and this kid was being such and I was,
I was joking around when I said it,
I turned to Mike,
I'll go,
I'll give you $20.
You've punched this kid in the face.
And with his comedic timing was brilliant.
He didn't miss just bomb.
And this kid went back and it was,
who all hell broke loose
name,
but he's a legit savage.
He's the wrong guy to fuck with.
Well,
I mean who?
This guy and then the all this,
you know.
And then he's on the sidewall showroom.
No,
no.
Out on the patio bar February.
It's like the wild west.
There has a story about fucking this made sit up.
Never heard my picture of favor,
man.
Listen,
do you don't have to.
I just don't know if I,
well,
you know Mike favor men?
No,
really?
I don't know.
I just met him recently.
He's a great dude.
He had this story about,
he was beaten off in his hotel room and the made opened up the door and the maid
freaked out.
He was like,
oh,
come on,
shut the door,
shut the door.
Shut the door.
He's like the only guy ever to get caught beating off and fucking a maid like
ever.
Like you really did it.
He said,
I go,
what?
Did she do?
Hair?
No,
no.
I go,
what do you wish she looked like?
She goes,
it wasn't no prize.
Right.
It looks like Feynman.
Mike's a good dude.
He's a good dude.
He's a very good cook.
Oh wait.
He's the guy that's functional shifts.
Punchy and Ray Donovan.
He doesn't that picture.
I know the picture.
It's the hat,
man.
Whatever it was.
It was.
It was like a movie scene.
This kid.
And he was just,
you know,
favor men will punch you in your fucking face.
He's crazy.
He's always been crazy.
He's a good dude though.
The wife beater right there.
He is with the homeboy
from the radio.
What's his name?
Uh,
oh yeah.
uh,
Frazier.
Smith.
Frazier's man and Dom Barris.
He's a Boston guy.
Frazier Smith used to have a radio show here.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah.
He's favor missing originally.
Favorite mint.
It's just going to say he looked like the funniest guy at the barbecue.
And you switched to a picture of barbecue with favor men.
Joey Diaz and Ralphie May.
The day nine 11 happened the day they shut down all the flights,
the day the shit hit the fan.
We all got high.
We went to Baja fresh.
We ate some Burrito's and we stared at the sky.
It's like two,
there's no planes,
there's no fucking planes.
And then we went over to Ralphie's place and Ralphie and favor men lived like in
the same area and famously a gardener then fibrin.
No.
Ralphy.
Uh,
it was Gardner coach and horses.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Actually,
you know what we went to,
I'm sorry.
We went to favorites place and Ralphie came over to buy weed.
Just favor.
That was your September 11 cause you used to live in that
same building.
Yeah.
This guy in the world because this is Armageddon and we're going to need to eat
someone famous and had some good weed.
No,
he had some good weed and we were like,
well the world is ending.
Let's go get fucked up.
So we went and got high.
It was me and Diaz and favor,
Ben and Ralphie May and it was 2001 it was the day when we were,
we were just sitting around smoking weed talking about how crazy it was like
this might be where it might be in the middle of a war.
We were thinking at that moment in time that this is just the beginning.
The planes flew into buildings,
but what of Shit starts happening left and right.
Like what if we start seeing missiles headed to la?
What if we see la hit with a nuke?
Like fuck,
oh that's just as likely as two planes flying into buildings and the same day.
So we were freaking out and we're all getting high together.
So
I was in Amsterdam at the zoo,
three o'clock at the zoo and Amsterdam is feeding time.
That's 3:00 PM is 9:00 AM in New York City.
And I had been there before for it and I knew I wanted to be in front of the
lion cages when a,
at three o'clock when they're throwing the meat out and like it's cool to lions
start,
they can smell the demeanor and the back and they'd start getting start pacing
and Growlin and,
and uh,
there's these metal doors and they're scratching on it and shit.
It was pretty cool.
And then they opened the metal doors and they grabbed the meat.
So when the,
when the,
when the planes hit,
I was watching the lions rip raw meetup.
Oh,
see I,
I would assumed all the animals would have run for the hills knowing nine 11 it.
How come they
come?
They don't do that.
The Netherlands is so open minded.
Why don't they feed those animals animals?
Why do they have to feed him?
Well,
they want to eat animals more important.
Why is Baja fresh open on nine 11
our troops need to fuel up.
They were a part of healthy carbs.
That's what it is.
Our troops need to fuel up.
We need beans and the beans and Jalapenos
by first supports the troops.
Mike favorite walking,
the guy that actually put together that boxing match with all the comics.
Oh,
one of the guys had cerebral palsy and I was like,
that's not good.
If it's Josh blue against crazy legs,
Fon Saika.
Either one of those guys should not be hitting each other and then maybe falling
on each other and headbutting each other on the way down in a chair.
How far can they fall?
They're both going to get fucked up.
Shit.
I not hear about a comedy boxing match.
And when did this happen?
Oh,
it's spilling too.
He filmed it.
He's like make trying to make it a show and it's really good.
How many boxes?
I know too much about brain damage,
but how did this happen?
When did this happen?
Yeah,
if they were men.
And a rusty
spot.
Who?
Rusty?
Rusty.
Duly best six pack and a all of comedy kids shredded.
No doubt.
I have two,
three packs.
I got to vernal hernia,
ventral ventral hernia.
Do you really have my,
my six pack split.
Did she get that shit fixed?
Yeah,
I uh,
Bravo had one of those heady.
Oh really?
Yeah,
he did two of them.
One on each side.
He got it fixed.
You can't ever had a problem I guess.
Yeah.
Ventral just means front.
I've found out through my doctor Google.
It's pretty intense.
They uh,
they put like a,
like a Web Mesh.
Yeah.
Mesh and in your skin and they sell it in and they,
so the,
uh,
the area that's wounded comes more strong at that.
And my umbilical hernia.
Then I coughed myself into a groin hernia that I haven't had fixed and now I
have a ventral hernia.
I showed it to Christ.
You're on his podcast.
He took pictures,
so that'll be up next week.
Jesus,
excited alien bursting out of your chest.
What is it?
What is it from your six pack?
A rots in your guts.
Start to only in a position.
I was trying to stretch my back like I was doing sit ups off.
No,
no.
That's how I noticed it.
It doesn't work or anything and you don't feel anything?
No,
no.
I was trying to lean off the back of a bed,
like what my most of my body and I leaned down and then my fucking,
this hump comes out of my chest like alien and Bingo looked down at it and it
audibly screamed and I'm like,
Oh shit.
That can't be good dude,
dude.
Seriously.
Imagine if you were really possessed,
what would you do if like [inaudible] bed and I'd be fine if you,
you sat back and you're like,
what the fuck?
And it's like a little jack-o-lanterns underneath your skin,
moving around your stomach.
What would you do,
Doug Stanhope would you go to Jesus?
I do exactly what I'm doing with this hernia and the other 90 is ignore it.
Oh,
you can't ignore a fucking jack-o-lantern deem and living in your gut.
I have you saw poking through skin and moving around and laughing at you.
You'd have to address it.
No,
I would drink.
And then as Tom,
when you drink,
it's easy to ignore.
Obvious.
But that's,
that's been my life medical plan.
Like my family,
we know you don't go to the doctor unless you got a bullet wound.
Right.
And a,
I just got insurance.
Tented,
the phrase,
it's just a flesh wound.
Uh,
I just got health insurance,
uh,
under the deadline.
Uh,
and I actually,
uh,
I,
I stopped drinking January 1st.
I blacked out in Philadelphia.
Oh,
good story.
Busted my head open.
I got six stitches.
See a nice scar.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Uh,
and I didn't,
I,
you know,
it's too bad.
W was the figure out what caused it.
I got drunk and fell down.
So just hang on.
I've heard the story,
so I'm going to use this opportunity to piss.
So you,
you,
so you blacked out just because you were drunk and he fell down.
Does it ever happened before?
I mean,
I've,
I've uh,
for,
uh,
for a second,
over the years it's happened a couple times,
but man,
getting drunk and falling down,
it's one thing.
But if you did you black out or I kind of black,
I was not working.
I was,
I did helium in Philadelphia for New Year's Eve.
Great Room,
had three,
uh,
sold out shows,
fantastic fucking night.
Uh,
it wasn't New Year's Eve night.
I had a,
cause New Year's eve was on a Wednesday.
They had me do those stay for the Friday.
Saturday,
I'm off January 1st and I went out by myself.
I actually stayed in and worked all day and then I went out about eight,
nine o'clock and I watched the fiesta bowl and I had 10 Sierra Nevada's.
My brother was at the game and,
uh,
I texted my brother,
I was texting my brother Greg game,
love you,
Bro.
And just,
uh,
fell forward off a stool.
And His fucking hit the tile ground.
And this guy grabs my arm and he's put,
lifted me up and he goes,
we got to call an ambulance.
And I go,
fuck that.
I don't have health insurance.
I woke up once my head hit the ground by the way,
but this guy goes,
we got to call an ambulance.
I go,
fuck that.
I don't have health insurance.
Don't you dare call an ambulance.
I go,
how far is the hospital?
He said two blocks.
I go two blocks and you were going to call an ambulance.
It's like 15 grand.
Oh my gosh.
You know,
and I,
so I walked to the hospital,
but you know,
I didn't have health insurance and uh,
you know,
had the Obama deadline been January 1st that have been covered?
What?
Does anybody understand this?
Oh,
do you know anything about it?
No.
I got a,
at some points I met,
uh,
insurance person and I have like catastrophic insurance.
So if I get like really fucked up in a car wreck,
they'll cover that.
I don't,
again,
I don't go to doctors.
It's just not something that I don't either.
It's probably a good move,
so I don't have any idea how health insurance works.
Yeah,
know if I,
if I need to get out of a social situation really badly,
I'll go to a doctor because I know that they're going to go,
oh,
this do you have to be admitted right away and I'm going to,
sorry honey,
I can't go to bed and breakfast with your parents like I promised when I was
drunk.
That's a fucking great strategy.
As long as you can keep the wheels on.
It's a great strategy because there's a lot of cars to keep rolling down the
hill and they make a lot of squeaky noises and but they still get there somehow.
How many surgeries have you had?
Many.
How many,
and you're in perfect Europe.
What kind of insurance do you have that you can get your blood drip,
drip.
The point is,
he's in perfect physical condition,
doesn't smoke cigarettes.
He said,
I've had one surgery that I got for free on a trade out by asking for it on my
website.
Hey listen,
I'm not a,
I'm not denying that.
You make a lot of good points.
I would never tell anybody to take the path that I've taken.
Like physically.
It's not a good move.
Yes he would.
I wouldn't unless you really want it to,
but if you,
you,
you tear your knee doing something,
don't keep doing it.
You get six months of Rehab.
I just couldn't wait for the six [inaudible] mad when I see a friend that's into
MMA because I know he's going to die an ugly death.
You know,
all bullshit aside.
I'm s I am sad when I see a guy who doesn't know that he shouldn't be doing it.
There's a lot of guys that like wind up,
not Jujitsu.
Jujitsu is for anybody.
Anybody can do Jujitsu but competitive MMA,
there's some guys that just shouldn't be doing it.
Good.
Cause at the end of this podcast,
Tom and I are going to Jujitsu each other in a death match.
It's going to be the biggest girls'
slap fight
I'm getting hit.
It's a complete different story though.
You know,
I've had a,
I've had two knee surgeries,
I've had nose surgery.
Those are the two big nose surgery.
I'm actually a three knee surgeries now that I think about it.
Cause I had two on one knee,
had an ACL,
reconstructed,
and then I hadn't been a minute meniscus scoped.
And the other one I had the ACL reconstructed.
And then I had my nose opened up cause I had a,
when you fernet surgeries,
I remember my cousin did a pilot.
My cousin did a pilot in 1984 with Christopher Lloyd and he's the guy from
Massachusetts.
You just,
you,
your snapshot was in the paper in the back row of a thing.
Everyone talks about it.
So it was a big deal.
And I moved to La.
I saw Christopher Lloyd at the bar,
at the Improv,
and I went up.
I go,
hey,
I don't know if you remember,
I don't want to approach you,
but grant Forzberg is my cousin.
And you did a television pilot with them in the 80s and he goes,
oh no,
I did a lot of TV shows.
How do you get that fucking,
yeah,
well fuck that.
You forget a TV show.
But when you forget surgeries,
we think about how many TV shows that guy's hat.
I've only had four surgeries,
but you are pretty manual.
But you forgot one.
Actually,
now that I think about it,
it's three knee surgeries.
Well it's,
you start treating your body like your car,
you know,
you blow out a tire,
you go,
all right,
you've got to get another tire.
Can they fix it?
As long as they can fix it.
But shit that gets weird is like spinal shit.
And that's why I've been getting this Regina King Shit.
The Regena keen stuff.
You haven't stopped disc,
mixed martial arts.
Well Not Jujitsu.
I haven't stopped you just gotten into Regina cane from some Nazi doctor
Mengele Jr has got you on the yellow stuff.
I had to take a break,
the yellow shear,
uh,
from Jujitsu because of this injury.
So I'm trying to get back in shape to do it again is just too much fun.
You know,
it's like,
that's why I sympathize with you guys smoking cigarettes.
I understand what you're doing.
You're just my,
my,
uh,
what I do,
the risks.
I take a seat Africana physical.
You're going to see Shawn Rao shaking and anally scratching his arm.
It needs some more.
The yellow shit man.
Heat my blood.
I need more of the yellow shit.
It's not cheap.
That's the other problem.
You think your house making money.
Do you think Obamacare was heck your Dick,
man,
Sean,
you're not that young anymore.
I saw,
yeah,
I don't think it is.
I don't think it's covered by any insurance.
It's what's called off label.
I saw you can only buy it in bitcoin.
It's that
Dojo
coin.
You could use doge coin too.
They accept now accepting Doge coin.
I made,
uh,
from the,
that thing with that dude is over 2000 bucks.
That's amazing.
2100 bucks going to him.
Yeah.
We uh,
we had,
he will donate bitcoin and I would treat the bitcoin like it was real money and
then I would take whatever anybody donated in Bitcoin and send it to my friend
who's living in the Congo.
And uh,
he's helping pygmies in the Congo.
It was like building the wells and shit.
So he's going to send a,
you know it's going to be real actually.
Fuck it.
I'll double it.
Whatever it is.
I'll go wherever they have.
All right.
Whatever other people put in,
I'll,
I'll put in the exact same amount.
So I think it's like 2100 bucks.
It's pretty cool because the guys living in the Congo,
you know,
I mean key.
He used to be a mixed martial arts fighter and he just went down there for like
a vacation just to see what it was like.
You know,
sue and he fell in love with these people.
Like this idea that these people in the Congo,
these pygmies are these like really suppressed people that are forced to work in
mines and they don't have any,
no one's taking care of them.
There's no medicine,
there's no water.
Then I'm clean water.
So he's building them house and shit and it's really amazing.
It's amazing shit.
Judge.
Do you want to put a disclaimer though?
Like I'm a maximum amount cause you don't want it to be like,
I don't want no more than like 50 grand.
You can go fuck yourself.
That's crazy.
I like the pygmies,
but come on.
Yeah,
because I mean it's bitcoin.
Some guys just going like,
Oh yeah,
here's the two h is the,
that's what's weird about it.
It was
like,
it varies.
Like one day it will be worth 2,900 bucks or a 1900 bucks.
The other day it'd be worth 2100 bucks.
It totally varies from day to day.
It's strange.
It's like,
um,
it's like,
it makes a lot of sense if you don't know what it is.
Do you know what it is at all?
You ever follow it?
The bitcoin thing,
it's really hard to follow.
No,
I can't.
I can't do basic math.
Well,
it's not even that we had this guy,
Andreas Antonopoulos explain it to us in very clear terms.
We still were like,
these are
beers.
He explained it,
but essentially it's got a very,
a set number of bitcoins that exist.
And so inflation is sort of removed from the equation.
Gold Standard.
Sort of similar,
but it's all an understanding.
Understand either.
But it's all done on computers.
It's all like ones and Zeros,
you know?
I don't know if it's a good idea.
I don't know if it's a bad idea,
but it seems to be a,
at least a person could.
It's like we all agree like you,
you live in a small town.
So I think in a small town you get a better sense of community and we'd kind of
all agree that,
you know,
like if you go to a place in their selling sandwiches,
like how much is the sandwich is five bucks.
That sounds right.
It's makes sense if,
but if we didn't have money and we had used some sort of a barter system,
which still figure out what's worth what,
you know,
that's what we would do.
How many sandwiches are available.
Yeah.
And,
but we're,
we're trapped in this idea that money is the only way to do it.
Dollars,
corridors,
fives,
20.
This is the only way to do it.
It's not the only way to do it.
If enough fucking people agree to go this bitcoin route,
it's already established like this is a real possibility and everybody's poo poo
in it.
Like it's a joke and it is kind of a joke in some ways because I mean a map.
Yeah,
you're right.
A magic.
The gathering was the fucking,
the big server that went down like we didn't even wait a minute.
You had a magic the gathering exchange and it became my,
the biggest bitcoins sites in the like what
the fuck,
like magic and didn't have the right security.
The whole thing is set up wrong.
Winds up losing 350 million plus dollars in bitcoins,
like the direct equivalent of like the guy,
the guy gets robbed and everybody has their money in.
This exchange just gets fucking robbed but it's still going.
It's still going.
See how it can shut us down.
We want to throw in some fucking smart as far as age just gets all smart on us
and we have to sit tomorrow and I want you to get goofy but,
but this is a fascinating thing.
In our time we're seeing an alternative to dollars,
the fright,
but then I have alternative.
Everyone goes to what?
Internet currency and then someone could easily rob your or banks or everything.
What are you doing with regular money though?
Or you can just lose your iPhone.
Yeah.
Alternative to [inaudible] the guest list.
Do you write the number down?
All you have to do is write the number down.
It's not that hard.
Um,
oh great.
Another currency.
I'm broken.
Hey,
good smart.
As Barb served one of us up on my strategy to introduce you and your
ability to retain knowledge,
rub it in our face.
Routine knowledge.
I retained affirmation.
Yeah.
So the,
the,
the knowledge of it.
The reason why I keep talking about it over and over again.
So knowledge is not sinking in,
so I don't really get it.
So I,
I talk about it over and over again.
Your reaction to it and you're like,
whoa,
that's fucking crazy.
And then slowly but surely it becomes knowledge.
People talk to me in analogies that then I can get it.
And I try to do that with when I'm trying to do a bit that other people might,
I'll,
I'll go.
It's like this.
Okay.
If you can make it stupid for me,
like a kid.
Okay,
honey,
imagine if you had two apples.
Jimmy's stole one of your apples.
I do that all the time.
I think that's a great way of communicating fucked up ideas.
But even then,
but it's both.
It's important to say it.
Use the big words and then go.
I mean it's like this like this,
so okay.
You get,
now you understand the big word.
I just learned with the stupidity.
I needed to learn it.
Especially if you're on stage and you're telling me the joke because if you do
that,
you can actually make someone laugh at something they ordinarily would argue
with you about.
Right.
You could just sneak it in.
Yeah.
Okay.
We were both on the same page.
I love you.
Don't we have some ad copy to read?
I'm just here to do the advertisements.
The ad copies over forever.
Come on one more ad.
Do you see that?
Did you have a drone?
I dare you make me uncomfortable.
The in Japan.
A drone yet that Jerome went into the radiation in Japan and just flying around
like the deserted cities and it's so creepy cause that's his houses.
No,
but just it hasn't been touched since it happened.
It's really a great,
great.
What do you try to scare the fuck out of me?
The only thing that scares the fuck out of me more than radiation is sharks.
Oh,
I like the radiation
is going to kill you in the ocean one.
The sharks would kill you first.
How about that?
Do you not swear that up?
Fuck that dude.
I go in the water up to my waist in Hawaii and I panic every time because last
time I was there,
a woman got killed by a shark.
That's real.
Like if I was there and a woman got murdered by the Werewolf.
What'd you go in the woods?
You'd be like,
I'm not going in the fucking woods.
But they're like,
hey,
I'll go in the water,
but no,
we're going to Hawaii tomorrow.
The next day I won't go in the water.
Fucking tiger sharks,
man.
They're too scary.
Tiger sharks and bull sharks.
Those are the scariest ones.
So you know,
in that fucking,
the whole movie jaws was based on something that happened in freshwater.
Oh,
the New Jersey thing.
That's fresh water.
It was,
oh wait,
no,
that's not the New Jersey thing.
There was a rash of New Jersey Shark attacks in the early 19 hundreds.
Yeah,
that's it.
It was in a river.
Fresh water was all right.
That's what's fucked.
Does a thing called a bull shark that swims in a fresh water.
They swim so far in fresh water that they saw them in Illinois.
They have them up the Mississippi River in fucking Illinois.
A shark.
Well that's Jesse from your,
uh,
that's more reason we need stronger immigration policy.
That's why you can't take my guns from me,
Doug.
Staying hope.
I literally saw a wall build a fence.
That's what I say.
I literally saw song the other day that was talking about prying a gun from my
cold dead hands.
It was,
that was the song is like,
you can come get my gun from my cold dead hands.
Like this guy thought about that,
wrote it down,
said fuck.
And I'm putting this shit on wax.
But you heard it.
Oh,
I heard the whole song.
I listened to the whole song.
So someone's putting it out.
Someone's on his side.
There's some,
uh,
what's the guy's name?
The stapler guy from office space that played even route.
If you can't get the fucking reference right away,
drop the joke,
Stan.
Yeah.
Stephen root man of constant stuff.
It's right.
There's a long way to get to this pointless reference he played.
He played the record guy that said the guys,
the thing with the thing,
the man of constant sorrow and George Clooney and the,
yeah,
see he put it on wax to it wasn't [inaudible] Greenwood,
was it?
Yes.
Let's just say yes.
That's what I'm saying.
Almost that guy,
Lee Greenwood,
nothing was happening in his career.
He had that one song.
I'm proud to be an American fucking nothing's going on in his career and
his career was on fire.
I always tell Henry Phillips to write a Christmas Song.
They're so desperate to have another Christmas song that they will play any
fucking thing about Christmas.
They're so desperate to have a Christmas song.
They went with the Hanukkah song.
You remember that?
Yeah.
They will pick a song every year.
Grandma's still got run over by a reindeer fucking 30 years later.
They can't to have one more.
Henry Phillips get off your ass and get a fucking Christmas.
How about they don't even come up with new Christmas cartoons?
The same fucking cartoons.
The Grinch stole Christmas.
It would be CGI now and the Grinch should be like crushing villages a be evil
again.
He'd be very demonic.
Wouldn't be so sweet and cuddly.
But what they did with Batman probably too that with the Grinch.
Did you watch the latest Batman?
I've never watched it.
Where the tragedy occurred,
where those people get shot in Colorado for whatever reason ever with a
Christian Bale and uh,
what's his name?
We die.
I've heard it's awesome.
That's the greatest family I'm done with.
The dye was the greatest Batman ever.
The dark night.
That's it.
I didn't say it best Batman ever because of what happened in Colorado.
It's too bad that it happened.
No,
no,
no.
The reason I don't watch it is because of that.
Yeah.
One of the comics from the comedy works guys.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Serious business.
Oh,
that guy.
That guy because whatever,
for whatever reason,
that movie's connected in my head.
Yeah,
that's fucked up.
I can't just watch that movie for watch that movie.
I'll kind of like get weirded out.
But these parties,
one shooting weird you out.
[inaudible] I saw it in the theater after that happened like a few weeks later.
And then you're in the theater thing and you're,
you're looking at the fucking exit doors.
I'm not saying it's logical,
I'm just,
Oh,
I don't go to actual movies.
I saw it at home,
but I had to see with Bingo and I can see why the man was traumatized.
I'm not traumatized.
I just chose not to see it because I thought about seeing it a few times and I
just kept getting that thing in my head that they're a bunch of people fucking
died while this movie was being made.
That's all it is.
I mean,
it doesn't make any sense.
I know.
It doesn't make any sense.
I'm not like arguing the logical,
you know,
uh,
that,
that it makes sense that I had this weird thing.
I love that.
While you're saying this,
you're slamming ice India glass.
I know this doesn't make sense,
but I just need a drink.
I need a little something to take the edge off.
I'm not,
there's no edge talks.
10 I'll put up there here.
I know.
It doesn't make any sense.
I'm not.
Why would they ever make another superhero movie?
We've seen they made another superman.
I love the captain America.
They're fun.
They're stupid as fuck.
You know he's going to be the captain America Comic Book.
When I was a kid,
one of the few that I looked at and it was the lamest dude.
The Subaru.
Yeah.
He couldn't fly and to fly on the thing,
and then he had the shield.
He was like the biggest pussy superhero ever.
And then in the late seventies there was a black character called the Falcon.
All right.
How about
Captain America would be getting his ass whooped in his black friend.
That Falcon would come and save him.
Yeah.
Well that's how it usually happens in real life.
You Negro,
you call your friend,
but it was cute how they,
he's a fucking mask.
You're good.
But a black character couldn't get his own comic book.
He had,
he likes introduced.
He had like Captain Marvel.
Marvel was a little bit more bold.
Marvel had blade,
blade
was a superhero.
He was a Buckeye.
Nightcrawler.
I'm sure they came out much.
He wasn't really black.
Well I guess he was more like,
that's demonic.
I had Roger from what's happening
Geeky,
but he was the smart one
group
that was the Roger of my social circle.
A captain.
America was still fun.
I know.
It was stupid.
I know the premise is stupid,
but it's still fun moving.
Just nonsense.
He watching nonsense for a couple hours laughing,
you know,
having a good time,
watching space.
Ships get shot up.
I've missiles and whatever.
It's stupid,
but it's fun.
Nobody got shot.
You can enjoy though.
Why of people got shot.
A lot of people died and Captain America movie in the promoted.
You forget where your heart was it the beginning of this conversation.
I forgot my true loyalty.
I,
uh,
I know it doesn't make sense that I don't watch the Batman movie and I've come
close to wash it a few times,
but I always think,
think,
I don't want to fucking shit.
That's what it is.
Because of that,
that guy did joker.
He was amazing.
I'm sure.
I mean,
uh,
that heath ledger character was fucking incredible.
He was amazing.
Wait.
Yeah,
no I can't.
That's the one that heath ledger was that he was the chosen around when that was
the note pain pain and Christian Bale was the,
was the,
was the Guy Heath Ledger's years ago,
she became my grandpa.
My grandpa doesn't know what the fuck he's talking about,
but yells about it.
Fucking John Wayne,
John Wayne movie.
I know every time I say ledger on stage,
I know how dated it is during the new Batman.
No,
right.
I didn't say he was in the new Batman.
He was in the one that the premiere shooting.
No,
he wasn't.
No one was the bane lock up.
The Bain one was the one where the guy came and then a year ago or two years
ago,
2012 the 12th.
Yeah,
so may I believe it was may.
I like to think I remember my shootings,
John Wayne,
the number one problem with Captain America.
My audience comes to me when there's a big shooting waiting for my response
as Malaysian planes went down every six or eight weeks,
I would be the prime minister of the shooting.
That has to come up with a joke.
That's an odd fan base is all I'm saying.
I'm aware of that.
I agree.
It's very odd.
It's what you get.
You putting out an odd vibe,
you know,
you live in the middle of nowhere.
What is death squad squad to me?
No one ever figured it out.
Well,
it's funny,
I was in London.
I don't use the word anymore,
just carry the theater.
They go.
Some people showed up and they,
they said they were with the death squad.
I was playing the Solo theater.
It's just like really prestige and or in London.
And I got to play this,
the,
uh,
this,
this theater man and then fucking,
they're really proper therapy.
This,
the origin of,
and they were
like death squad from the Ob.
Anthony Show was a Eddie Bravo bread band,
Tate me and uh,
it,
I shut up in the Eddie,
uh,
and uh,
Eddie Bravo was,
you know,
black belt,
Jujitsu champion and Tate's this big gorilla.
And uh,
Jeff Tate to no,
no,
no.
After,
quickly after crusher,
and I did our picks for the ultimate tour,
we got down and sat down with his children and wife for dinner and he mentioned
Jeff Tate.
I'm like,
Fuck Jeff Day,
why didn't I pick Jeff?
Yeah,
he's a great comic out of Cincinnati.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Oh,
so you thought it was talking about that guy Tait Fletcher is a big giant guy
and oop from opie and Anthony Goes,
look,
Joe Rogan showed up at the desk squad.
That's it.
And then it was a joke.
We were laughing.
Ha ha ha.
And then somehow or another people kept using it and then,
you know,
many years later,
Brian started the uh,
these videos.
Remember those videos?
They Rachel desks going podcast.
Yeah.
We used to do these videos like at shows and uh,
then he started the desk squad podcast network.
The videos were all just us hanging around at shows like you would do these
little clips of stupid shit that was happening.
It was actually,
we did the Joe show and there's all this extra footage that was just bullshit
stuff inside.
Just made like quick one minute videos.
Every time I see a death squad tee shirt in my audience,
which is often,
I always say,
hey,
death squad is point a to point them out on stage.
It's a weird name and I'm going to stop doing that by my tee shirts.
You've got your tee shirts anyway.
It's a weird name too.
That's why I stopped using it,
but I just stopped using it because it just sounds too crazy to use.
But feel free to keep using it.
I know.
I never knew the origins.
I just,
I assumed that was your network.
No,
it's Brian.
Well,
Brian started his podcast and he used that name.
The new sort of represented all of us.
No,
I just have this.
Yeah.
What is a network?
You know,
what does that mean?
Hell have a network of guys that I'm friends with his comedy officially.
Hey I a bill burr and a,
yeah,
sure I'll do that.
All that means is that you are joining up with a bunch of other people.
So in that sense,
yes.
But it's completely unofficial.
So like my podcast is joined with Ari's podcasts is joined with Joey Diaz.
His podcasts is joined with Dunkin's podcast is joined with all the desk squad
podcasts at red band produces is joined with Dr Burge.
Crisis podcasts is joined with Tom Seger and Christie.
But it's all completely,
because we're friends,
there's no agreement,
but we all support each other.
We all constantly like all things.
Comedy is like that as well.
I'm with tracks.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah,
yeah.
And they just want to,
you know,
comedians to,
get some beautiful,
do their own thing.
Yeah.
But we're not like,
there's no like official connection.
We just saw.
What it does for me is make me more disciplined in that.
Okay.
Now I guess I told Bill Byrd tacitly that I will do this on a weekly basis
rather than go fuck it.
No one cares.
Yeah.
So yeah,
I'll,
I'll be better about putting it out.
Like I feel like I have an obligation,
but you should hire a guy that just turned the mic on.
It's so fucking I do.
It's so easy just to hire a guy,
but I mean all the time,
whoever he is all the time.
You should have a guy that just turns to my con.
It's so easy for you.
It'll be fun for you.
I do.
You should do him every fucking day.
You should have a guy that turns a microphone on you every day just to let you
go.
Just just turn the microphone on and lets you go.
And then a bill burst style.
Have you ever done one by yourself?
I did a bunch of them in the beginning by Marcel.
That's amazing.
And he got scared to try it even though I know I don't have to put it out.
I have,
I've done it in between two where a guy like you like maybe need to take a leak
and you get up and I'll just keep going and even for 10 minutes but it becomes
easy after a while you fall into a pattern.
I'm sure it would be at,
but initially even when if I'm doing a set where I really,
uh,
all new shit too much new shit do about to do a,
a,
a DVD,
whatever,
I will get Brian my manager and make him like I just have to say this out loud.
You have to stand there but I can't say it out loud to myself.
Okay.
This segues into this and then I'm going to do this.
Say it out loud in front of someone other than the audience.
Important?
No.
Before a show.
Like if I,
if I,
if I like when I worked at UK and I have to abandoned two thirds of my set cause
it doesn't translate and I've been writing a bunch of new shit that I don't
really know and I have to say it out loud before I go on stage.
Okay.
This is the segue.
This gets me into this.
I'll make Brian listen to me say not the whole set but the bullet points and
what the segway is,
cause I couldn't say it to myself,
which I really am,
but I need someone standing there,
right to say it out loud.
And that's what a podcast by myself would feel like.
Nah.
Yeah,
I see where he was.
But it's,
it's more of a freestyle thing if you choose to just go over what's going on in
the news every day.
There's always something in the news.
It's fascinating.
The,
the,
the beautiful thing about the time we're in,
if you wanted to do a solo podcast is all you have to do is go to your Twitter
feed.
You know,
I have,
um,
a guy works for me,
Matt stags,
he's my publicist for the podcast and every day he sends me,
um,
uh,
news and afternoon news and evening news in the morning news.
It's all just the most fucked up shit that's going on in the world.
Fascinating things.
And Nd Day,
I've got 20 of them any day there's 20 subjects,
but he would just start.
Right.
But I think what you're talking about like just the,
the,
when you look at someone,
when you speak,
just things totally know what you're saying into the air and not looking at it.
And if I'm,
if I'm talking too much,
one of you will roll your eyes at me and I'll shut up and let the other guy
talk.
I don't have that.
But you don't have to do that.
It,
it's a totally different dynamic.
If you're doing a solo podcast,
like nobody wants you to shut up.
It's more about just not thinking about what you're saying.
Finding like a,
a like a channel in the river of ideas and just riding it and then just like
free balling.
You get like this comfortable free ball thing going on.
And as long as you're not too conscious or aware of what you're doing,
you,
you kind of catch this wave of creativity.
It's really fun.
You know,
I've only done it a few times,
but I've done it on stage a bunch of times and there's this thing that Brian
does,
um,
with um,
uh,
Jeremiah Watson have Thunderpussy.
Yeah,
that's the name though,
right?
Yeah.
Jeremiah Watkins,
Watkins,
sorry,
I said Watson.
Jeremiah.
I used to do it after shows,
but the better way to do it,
it's to do the whole show this way.
We just yell out like the audience,
he yells out subjects,
you just,
you don't,
you don't have any preparation whatsoever.
The audience,
he yells out subjects and then yelling out subjects.
You just add a,
like maybe a subject you never even thought about.
You'll just start talking about that subject and try to create comedy and under
the gun with a bunch of people watching,
a lot of times shit just comes up
and it sounds like is fun like that and then give you the ideas,
but it's different.
Yeah.
That it's not,
not a bunch of comics to come up with these wacky things.
Orangutang pineapples.
What?
Orangutan fire?
No,
it's fucking the audience.
It's the audience which comes up with the dumbest ideas that are the easiest to
play off of sometimes.
Yeah,
like whenever you see like whenever there'd be an inch,
a improv group.
Oh,
you know what?
Who Says Sucking Dick?
It's not always,
that's three nights ago.
They just heard second dick from the audience.
Now remember,
always improv troupes.
They go,
okay,
give us a word.
And it was always,
the first word was always someone in the audience dildo.
It was always like,
no,
I found the level of the crime.
Know what genre of film?
Everybody always says porn.
He says silent movies.
They all say porn you got,
and if they do say silent movies,
you know every fucking 45th show,
you abandoned the porn reference and go silent movies.
Okay,
we'll see.
We can come up with.
Then she got that shit memorized.
There's a silent born,
you know those guys that used to work the crowd.
That was a big thing.
Like guys who worked the crowd,
they would ask the crowd things and people go,
wow,
this guy just coming up with this on the fly.
And then you watch him three nights in a row,
like he's coming up with the same shit on the fly over and over again.
He's seeing people that had touched themselves.
They don't touch themselves.
Like he's just,
yeah,
he's not really,
oh,
when I say this guy did this,
no he didn't.
No,
he did.
I have a living.
You fuckhead yeah,
it's like the worst dirty trick of all time.
My first tour for David Trimble,
I first like road tour doing these triple gigs.
I worked with uh,
uh,
Matt.
Fuck,
I can't remember his Goddamn name now.
He was at Denver comic,
but he did crowd rap and it was kind of,
he knew what was coming,
but he'd go,
uh,
what do you do?
The last Gig in price Utah.
He's like,
what do you do?
Like the whole tour use getting,
I'm a pipe fitter,
I'm a meat wrapper.
And I'm like,
how are you getting this?
He was getting so fucking lucky with the easiest.
So we play price Utah,
which is a mining town.
What do you do?
I work in the mine and he had would've had whatever,
four or five people.
He said what do you do?
I work in the mine who work in the mind and I like finally you've got,
now you're on the fucking spot.
You're going to have to come up with some shit cause everyone is like does
anyone here not work in the mine?
And a girl raised her hand.
He said,
what do you do?
I work at the common go.
Oh Ah you fucking get lucky all in.
And you caught that on the right
river.
Come and go.
Whoever came up with that,
I thought that was a junk.
The first time I ever saw that shit was in Colorado Springs.
I stopped my car cause I didn't believe it was real.
I stopped my car,
I went wait,
that's the gas station is called common.
Go with a k like some sort of a wacky fucking whore house.
Cook,
Clean Comedy Knight with a k on Tuesday at the fucking the Clam House with a k.
The common come and go is the number one fucking bid on the menu at the clam
house.
That's when you just suck your Dick.
They don't,
no one says a word.
They push you in.
She just sucks your Dick and you go,
that's the come and go at the Clam House with the k Tuesday Nights Colony Knight
with a k cocktail cocktail time.
Do you remember those places that we'd have comedy Knight with a k?
Hang on,
I'm drinking cam check a vodka with a k.
Is that good little plug?
What is it?
Shitty vocat who's a,
is that ours or yours or did you bring that?
I brought that.
What is it?
I don't fucking come bearing gifts.
What is Cam Chat?
Kovach you know what?
I'd step all over my clothes or if I've told you.
Gotcha.
You um,
you know the,
uh,
they did this thing where they took vodka and they put it through one of those
Brita water filters.
Tried it,
heard the trick,
tried it.
We did,
you know,
straight vodka taste tests.
It didn't work for,
she said four or five times through a,
didn't work the same shifts.
It's all the same shit.
Years ago in San Francisco.
You remember the punchline,
they would put you at the Commodore Hotel Room downstairs?
I would always,
I was in the easy like Sunday morning sweet is that I had like a member of the
staff used to party.
Man.
I had a bunch,
I had like eight people back in my hotel room and everyone drank until the wee
hours banging the whole staff.
No,
no,
no.
But I remember waking up and there was like Tom was completely hung over and I
wanted to make some coffee.
And uh,
there was,
I was,
I thought it was a cup full of water and I put it in the coffee machine and then
it was vodka and coffee and I thought,
hey,
this might be the new reeses peanut butter cup.
Remember the commercial guys walking with the chocolate and he bumps into the
guy with the,
so I like to get a couple of steps of it.
It is definitely not the new reason they fucked up with that commercial.
They fucked up with that research.
Cumbersome
because if you take some chocolate and you dip it into peanut butter,
it tastes way fucking better than races.
That's where they fucked up cause he chocolate and peanut butter is really
delicious.
Booney receives,
shouldn't have fucking hate that.
Yeah.
It's pretty bland.
And a Brian brought me some,
uh,
it's all sugar dark chocolate bars one and we had them in the fridge and I don't
eat chocolate,
but there was nothing to eat and I had bought some pineapple off the street.
Fresh pineapple with a square of frozen dark chocolate.
Oh God.
It was good.
Dark chocolate is actually good for you.
It has a very high orac value.
How I feel so healthy right now.
Yeah,
it's high in antioxidants.
I really good for you.
I don't,
I don't like chocolate,
but I've had chocolate in Europe.
There was just orgasmic from the first bite.
You're like God damn good.
Every Deli Square.
Yeah.
Those are delicious.
Ghirardelli's like they used to have a real chocolate factory right there on San
Francisco and it was right down the street from the old cobb's,
the 150 seat cobb's.
Do you ever work that cops?
No,
I did all the time when I lived there.
I love that.
Right?
The greatest all time comedy clubs ever.
Fucking tragedy when they moved out of that place is the big place.
Tom Sawyer fucking great,
great club.
I mean it was 150 seats and tight.
Today's Tom.
Sorry.
All small fucking room.
He's a serious comedy fan.
That dude,
Tom Sawyer loves comedy.
I was playing the purple onion,
I guess 60 seat or when you were playing cops,
the new big room.
We came down to see you.
They just
for Millennians now,
like an Italian restaurant are there was,
it was always upstairs,
but I came down to see Rogan.
I'm playing a 60 cedar.
He's playing a 18,000 security cobb's comedy club,
whatever it think it's a fucking airplane hangar.
Then we hung out with you afterwards.
It's like two 30 in the morning.
It's,
they threw everyone out.
It's a staff party and someone had below.
Then I'm going,
I am,
I'm supposed to go do a live remote for a car show like it.
Good morning.
San Francisco TV live from a car show on Saturday morning.
And I go,
I'm not going to fucking make it.
I'm just,
I just did lines.
It's two 30 so I got one of the local comics,
uh,
Jason,
fuck,
don't let me forget your name.
I go,
listen,
will you go to the show as me?
Because the maids,
the man show is about to come out.
Red Band has footage of this.
Oh that's right.
Go down to the car show is me.
I'm delineating my small amount of authority to a local guy that I know will do
it.
He's like 10 years younger than me,
eight inches taller than me,
but I still had him come by my room and get my overcoat and my fucking knit wool
cap.
That's funny.
As my outfit and I have footage,
I have my own footage,
red books,
television.
It made a television.
Yeah,
he went down and the whole graphic on the Kyron on the bottom man show hosts
Doug Stan hope and he's just doing this straight interview as me.
You got it.
That's beautiful.
That San Francisco standing by to give us some insights on.
It's an interface between dare fucking homework.
I'm very fascinated with,
is that my space.com we're going to be talking all about it.
That hurts my feelings.
It hurts me.
How dumb that gutter
that wasn't good at Photoshop.
Oh,
this weekend we're at the cow palace.
Where the
or is it rotten cup?
I can never remember.
And a motorcycle show was taking place through tomorrow.
Another event that's taking place this weekend to actually for next week or week
and a half to sketch fest in San Francisco.
Watch them a lot.
I gave him my clothes worse.
Stan hope being one of those comedians.
And by the way,
I will just,
I'm taking my career in my hands here,
but it's all good fun.
This is fun.
And uh,
this,
uh,
Nasser won't take advantage of.
That's right hand and he understands that my job in my marriage,
the marriage,
so,
oh my God,
it doesn't
go anywhere for the listener.
It doesn't need to.
The Guy,
his comedy,
the guy on the Tan jacket,
he's comedy.
Well,
I'm a walking shot that's pretty ambitious for a morning show.
you know what,
I like to mix it up.
Tom.
They'd like to get artistic.
You get a morning show in San Francisco years ago and I was hungover as fuck.
And they go,
would you mind?
Uh,
we have to say was mourning.
We,
oh,
you were hung over it.
We have to do this,
uh,
cover this fencing exhibit or some event or something.
So I had to go down to this fencing place and they filmed it and like,
you know,
would you mind doing and comedian Tom Rhodes and like I've got the fencing
outfit on and the mask,
it's like I didn't need to be there.
It could have been anybody.
Anyone else that is standard and I'm fucking,
I'm still drunk and I'm not.
I have to offend somebody so I can get like an extra three people in the fucking
show.
Brendan Walsh did that for me.
What I was,
Andy threw a party at the bar that they filmed a animal house,
the oldest day in the night scene.
Mind if we dance with your dates,
the lever that,
so that bar still exists and there's a campsite out in the way back of Oregon
near there.
So we had this party at this campsite and we,
and I can't get cell phone reception and I'm playing Seattle.
So I had Brendan Walsh,
I couldn't do a phoner to promote my show.
So we went into town to that bar.
I called Walsh.
I go,
Hey,
will you do this a phone or in Seattle as me?
And it's a show I've been on before,
so yeah,
sure,
I'll do it.
So he did it and they're like,
wow,
you know,
Kinda,
you don't sound like yourself.
But they went through and Brendan Walsh did a whole interview as he was sick or
I have no idea what he said,
but he is bullshit was strong.
That's fucking funny.
Tom Rhodes don't pitch this thing if not the bathroom.
Yeah,
that's not the bathroom.
He's in there.
I've done that a lot.
Have you?
Bingo is caught me so many times trying to go into the closet.
No hotel room to take a piss that you go well that's the amount of times you've
woken up and found me.
How many times did I pissed all over my own shit and never knew about it.
I do it all the time.
The humidity,
I guess,
I'm trying to remember who told me this story,
but somebody opened up their drawer and they pissed on their sock drawer.
They opened up,
they went to their dresser and they pulled their sock drawer open and they just
pissed in there and I'm like,
how the fuck did you think your sock drawer was?
The toilet.
I've peed on this.
I'm sure you've done this dog peed in the corner of a lot hotel rope and that's
why we're talking about,
we saw you go through the wrong door thinking going to win.
You peed in the corner of a lot of hotel rooms.
A few of them just being plastered and like,
you know,
I was signed it and he thought I was there.
How many times bingos caught me doing that versus how many times she didn't wake
up that I did that and didn't know I did that.
That's those extra two shots.
Well,
your brain says it's over.
Doug Stanhope you say the fuck it is.
I was plastered in Ireland years ago and I went out the room door.
I thought it was going into it.
I was just drunk and half awake.
I just needed to pee and I'm in the fucking hallway naked and I was banging on
the door.
I'm like,
Hank girlfriend,
get come.
What the fuck are you doing?
Motherfucking door.
We already have this on a podcast.
Hennigan did that right there.
My manager and Henry Phillips both have stories walking out thinking they're
going into the bathroom,
walking out naked and the door shuts behind them and they're both naked in the
fucking hallway.
Go and then you instantly become John Ritter.
I haven't been,
there's no way.
That's not comedy.
You know what are you going already sober?
I,
many people know I don't have identification.
You do like a 20 year bid in a hotel.
You're working in a hotel for 20 years.
I'm a dude's coming down naked.
How many dudes come down Nagin during your entire career holding their cock and
balls is going [inaudible] Brian,
when he went into it like a locker,
a housekeeping door that was open,
grabbed a sheet or whatever,
put it over his dick.
I walked down to the hotel and they just gave him the key.
He didn't,
they didn't say ID or anything.
Oh,
one good thing about being old is people don't question your intentions.
Well,
I also get the get,
I really think it's going to make it old,
old guy out of the lobbyists quicker.
It's more common than we want to admit,
especially if people were drinking booze.
If people are drinking booze,
I think they're pissing in the hallway.
They're walking outside,
they're getting people get so dry.
I mean,
how many people we've been around,
they'd gotten so drunk they don't know what the fuck they're doing.
I mean,
how many people?
Lot stitches.
We're not,
we're not unique.
We're not unique.
You know,
you,
you add us can connect assaults.
All the fucking people are out there in the world that are drinking.
There's a lot of people walking down that hall with a Dick in their hand going
sheds here.
That could chunk.
That's the day you gotta Walk to the front desk with confidence.
You know,
we just got to have one hand on the Dick and the other hand,
like just casually explain your story.
You know,
some man like,
you know,
give it a towel,
take your shirt off.
My only problem at that drunk would be overexplaining it.
I'd be going,
listen,
I went to this bar,
it was seven o'clock I hadn't eaten or letting him suck your Dick just to make
the story way over the top.
I've never get the front desk to suck my Dick,
but I'm not Joe Rogan.
But could you imagine if you went to the front desk and the man was like,
look,
I'll give you the key,
but I want to suck your Dick.
You might let them at least put his dick in your mouth so you could tell people
about it.
You would think about it.
This is the most ridiculous thing.
You Tom Rhodes,
I'm saying ducks.
No.
Was He dug Stan hope letting a man,
you let it go.
You get the front desk.
Hello?
I'm just do it.
Just say stop saying you suck my Dick as a pre check cause I was going to call a
hooker,
but if I can't get it up,
if I do this,
when you give me gnostics on my penis before it weighs $350 on Arrow's guide.
Are you plugged in Sir?
Do you have the updated software?
Oh yeah,
you would do it just for the story of my life.
Yeah.
You train you and Tom Rhodes,
Tom Roach.
You wouldn't go in there.
Play in the UK.
I none of my material world,
but getting blown in a hotel hallway by a front desk man.
That's universal to it.
Well that's the other thing like the UK,
they demand a new shell every year,
right?
They want you to have like a show like this.
This is the,
you know,
the end of the world show in the UK.
They all do their shows kind of like plays where they title it has a beginning
and an end and a through line.
And what's that about?
Well,
I'm doing the Edinburgh festival this year.
I've never done it.
And Are you feeling,
are you going to succumb to that peer pressure where she's always wanted to do
it and I,
but I mean are you going to just do an hour or maybe do what I do know.
I'm not going to talk about Mike.
Going to make it all make sense.
Do you like guys,
you have a beginning,
a middle and an end,
right?
You know over there.
I never did.
But those guys do.
They have a themed show.
Jim Jeffries had,
can't remember the name,
but yeah,
it was about,
he takes this subject and it can vary.
There's this through line and an arch and then they're supposed to be a tidy
ending.
Eh,
it's about,
I've done a bunch of shows.
That's a fucking play.
Yeah.
I'm not into that.
I'm not going out and pounding people with jokes and I'm not an end in the same
way every night.
I'm not be getting the same way every night.
This is not going to be the same middle.
That's ridiculous.
You don't have to do with that.
Oh no you don't,
but they,
again,
the same way we have three comics.
Any comedy club you go into,
there's a an opener of feature which ends,
I'm plugging this everywhere.
Stop saying feature fuses the audience.
You're say your next act,
then your headline.
Middle it.
Yeah.
Just say the next act,
but if you say,
I'm middling for Stan Hope,
that's what you're really doing.
You're middling.
You did when you went out to eat to an audience of feature they think is a
headliner.
They don't know the difference.
Not only that it's gross because you know what you're doing.
It's the same exact spot doing the same exact thing.
You're trying to pretend it's more prestigious by calling it a feature.
That's stupid,
but a feature would sound like a headline or two.
A pedestrian audience who ends up England wasn't a thing of mega anybody ever
used in the east coast.
That was the thing that you would only use in the road for whatever reason.
Guys would use.
No point was in the UK.
They tend to do that.
They have a theme to show.
They have a,
you know,
this is what it's called.
They have opening acts.
Dot at Edinburg.
No,
no.
You,
you go out,
you perform your show.
I at some point I go,
I don't,
I don't know.
These rules don't apply to me.
Yeah.
I'm going to bring fucking Henry Phillips silver,
but in,
in clubs,
in England,
not usually.
A lot of times the best comedians,
the host opens a 20 the whole show is his thing.
In America,
we put on like open makers who have no experience and they don't know how to run
a show.
It's great when in England,
like a show's great from the start because you got,
and usually he's getting middle of most,
everyone else does 20 minutes sets and this guy,
it's like he's presented David Letterman.
We used to do that in Boston,
but that was the thing in Boston,
it would be like tonight is a dawn Gavin show and friends.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Steve Sweeney and friends,
Kevin Knox and friends,
they would,
Kevin,
Kenny Rogers in in France.
They did that all the time putting the fucking open miker hey no,
look he was,
every people know the first guy is going to suck.
Change.
Why you saying we can change if anybody can fucking do whatever the fuck did
they want?
It's you two.
You could both do whatever the fuck you want.
Yeah,
I'm talking about the United States,
about the club format.
Zig zags in Springfield,
Missouri.
Right,
right,
right.
But do you do it?
I don't do it.
I don't go out first and host the show.
Was I thinking about people who are still in comedy clubs where there people are
going to see comedy and not the comics.
So I still think they have to put three up.
I taught,
I've fucking
plow through.
I say,
I said this on fucking Bert Kreischer oh,
I see what she like one conversation.
But yes,
if you don't have a great herd of comics,
don't just put up a guy that's shitty because you think you need three.
Right?
But don't you think that the only way we ever get really better at comedy,
all of us is everybody needs to be thrown to the wolves.
There's gotta be a trial by fire.
I think if you see a guy who's got any town as well,
but Mike nights are for that.
Sometimes it's like the fucking owner.
I'll go up and do 10 because you don't have a third comic,
you don't need three,
you're totally right.
But when I used to take guys in the road with me too,
for the Diaz
security spot,
those guys like Dunkin and Ari,
both those guys,
when I started taking him on the road with me,
we're essentially open makers and they really didn't work professionally very
much.
We weren't making money off of it,
but I knew that they had potential.
So I figured if they can go on stage and break the crowd in like you,
you go out to a cold crowd every night,
a packed crowd that paid money and your use.
Oh that's,
Hey Mike Nights,
it's fucking great.
It's great for them.
And they both worked for worked for me.
Right?
But those guys have personalities that people love from hearing him on your
show.
That's just regular.
No,
no,
no.
This way before that.
Okay.
This was like in the 2002 2003 I was taking those guys the road with me and when
they were first starting out,
there was no podcast back then.
I didn't have any internet presence at all.
There was nothing.
Every show was just you do radio,
you go to town to local radio though I had nothing.
I had a message board that was like a pretty popular but you know,
I mean what does that mean?
Like had like 10,000 members or something like that.
The whole country,
you can't like fill a crowd at a comedy club,
something like that.
So it was all people that knew me most likely from TV and Dunkin would go up
first.
And by doing that it's like strength training.
It's like running up hills,
you know,
you just develop the ability to get out of the gate strong.
And I've watched them all like sort of like morph in that sense.
So I,
I see what you're saying like it is the best way to do it.
To have a guy like the Tom Rhodes and friends show and you go out.
So from the moment they go with the very least Tom roads coming up.
No,
I like going on at the end with the big fat,
our piece of cake.
You can do that to move the middle guy to the front,
put the shitty high in the metal.
You're not going to have an opener at the fringe festival,
Aria.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Just me for an hour.
The problem is the Middle Guy.
If the middle guys is shitty guy,
he's just going to get buried.
There's a big difference between getting buried by like if you have Diaz and
then after d as You have a guy who's just starting out.
He did that with an a heart.
We did it with.
Yeah,
that was,
that was not planned.
I mean,
yeah.
Well I mean we did it for fun.
We just still like in,
but Joey also knows you.
He loves you,
he throws you on stage,
gives you a great introduction and everybody knows that Joey's coming back.
But there is,
that's also part of being a great host is not front loading the whole shit where
you're,
yeah,
you don't open what you're closer and then bring out the fucking,
we need guy.
You have to ramp it up and then you're going to come back and they make it a
little stronger and you know how to do the show.
That's the technician.
That's the guy,
that's your manager of the fucking show.
But there's some guys that are really good,
they're really funny,
but they still need to be baby fucked.
There's some guys that you just can't have someone to strong gone before them.
There's just some guys,
they have a great style.
They have a great [inaudible].
The famous Mitch Hedberg incidents that happened all across the country were all
the wrong setup.
Like guy would go up,
it was the wrong middle act.
He would go up,
he would crush and then Hedberg couldn't follow them.
And then no one could ever say that Hedberg wasn't brilliant.
Headworks
but MC,
he was emceeing the first time I met him I was the Middle Act and he'd go up
with his jokes.
He has,
he had no,
yeah.
Hey,
how's everyone doing?
What are you drinking there?
And it would have a birthday,
like had no skill.
Junior stop,
go who I use now.
Like I'll fucking,
I,
I'd make Brian Hennigan,
my manager or Chaley go up and just say anything if there was no opening act,
just so junior didn't have to go up cold cause he's got nothing other than his
jokes.
He has no,
he doesn't have interpersonal skills as a friend.
I don't know if you necessarily need those.
If your jokes are strong,
you don't necessarily need those.
It's,
it's awkward at first.
But you know,
after a few seconds while we played a lot of fucked up venues where you kind of
have to address awkward situations and yeah,
you need that guy.
So even just my tour manager going up,
going,
hey,
everyone doing great.
Okay,
turn off your cell phone,
just announcements and then bring him up.
That makes just get people focused.
That's a good move.
That's a very good,
but yeah,
there's some people that are not going to be good MCS
guys that never respond to anything that happens in the audience.
They do not deviate.
Hey,
rap guys.
Mc has an actual fucking meaning in our world.
I'll go ahead.
Wow.
What are you trying to say?
You start in ration would be the Donald Sterling to don't start a rapport on my
show.
If you want to go on your fucking all things
comedy and started a rapport,
some east coast,
west coast type shit,
you go right ahead.
I'm not,
I'm not about that.
Doug.
Stan hope
death squad versus eight t.
See what does it.
Thanks comedy.
Jesus.
Getting an acronym.
Just wanting to make sure it was right.
Comedy.
You remember when you were starting out and you never had a fucking inkling of
the idea of having a career,
having a career or common?
It's just like a,
when you get those emails,
they're the saddest emails.
Well,
listen,
I've been thinking about doing comedy,
but like w like how do I get paid?
Well,
if that's how you're getting into comedy,
you're fucked.
When like,
uh,
opening acts ask you,
you know,
are open mic guys.
The same thing.
You know,
when can I expect to be paid from this?
That's a pretty early [inaudible] guys,
before they've ever stepped on a stage going like,
how am I going to get an agent out of this?
What you're supposed to want to get pussy out of this.
That's why you get to open Mike.
You want to impress the next funniest guy who's not funny.
That's your first goal.
The first time you make
the back of the room laugh,
it's the first time you feel like,
Holy Shit,
I might be a command in I,
I heard some comics laugh even more the first time when you went open miker you
heard of pro
laugh at something.
You said,
hey,
you're like,
Holy Shit.
I made a real comedian laugh.
I didn't just make the audience laugh.
I think when,
when we were starting out though,
you know,
you started out in what [inaudible] 90 yeah.
[inaudible] 88 okay.
84 babies.
You know,
it was just a dream of being able to get paid to do comedy,
but the idea of a career or,
or,
or
the first time I got paid,
it was either 10 or $15 and then I called my brother.
I go,
I'm technically a professional now cause I had just got paid.
And he goes,
does that mean you get to take off the protective head gear?
Well,
I've always said,
you know,
the toughest thing about being a comedian is keeping a straight face when they
pay you.
Right.
Wow,
you just gave me money for this.
Yeah,
no,
I've come to grips with the fact that I have a scam for a living and I had no
tough life and there's no way I should get paid for this.
But like when I did fraud telemarketing before this,
you go,
hey,
if you don't fuck them over someone else.
Well,
first time I ever got paid.
I worked for a guy named Warren Mcdonald and Warm Mcdonald had a brother that
was a,
he would do the Ronald.
No,
he would run the a open mic night.
Good guy.
I forgot his fucking name.
I want to say bill.
Anyway,
he was a,
the the guy who ran the open mic night and um,
I worked for him.
We used to do these norm LOFO gigs in the middle of fucking nowhere.
Did you ever do another Mambo Gig?
Did you ever do,
I don't know.
I never worked back east.
You never worked back in Vegas,
but you,
but you lived in Worcester,
like you went back and did gigs there,
right?
I went back lunch.
Was it stitches?
Yeah,
once open mic era.
So the first six months or year I ate shit.
[inaudible] 91
that was probably 1991.
Yeah,
I was still there.
I still,
I think it was still there until 91 or 92
back visiting.
I thought,
Oh,
I was it Mike.
What street it was on?
Was it a bigger stitches or was it the really tiny place that was next to the
paradigm?
Commonwealth.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
That is Commonwealth focused saturated old fossilized brain cell that just came
out and told you his street.
Yeah,
no,
that's it.
The Commonwealth App.
I wonder what the Paradise,
the Paradise Boston.
I was on bill burrs.
Uh,
what your Massachusetts?
Yeah,
I,
I'd mentioned czar rex.
Do you remember Zarek?
This is rx.
It was a syrup that you'd pour in the water as a kid like Tang,
but it was a syrup with a zebra on the front.
He's like,
yeah,
yeah.
He said,
wait,
wait.
Hey Cyrex.
We see a zebra and then just like that fucking Commonwealth brain cell.
He sang the theme song from Zurich's,
like he was speaking in tongues.
He didn't know what I at first and he goes,
wait a zebra,
and then he burst into song and had the theme song,
which I didn't even know you was.
You went to the real stitches.
If you went to Commonwealth,
have you went to the original stitches,
which was a next to the paradise.
The Paradise was a rock club.
Like you're really small rock club.
You're,
you're trying to end grand dies a rape scene for me.
I died so miserably.
But you got raped in a really historical place.
Did No,
I tied it was the most miserable fucking experience of my early comedy career.
Took it right in your dick hole at a really important place.
Fucking hated me.
That's zero rats back in production now.
And they started making,
what is this again?
What is rx?
Like I said,
it's stuff you put in like drink.
It's kind of like that stuff where you put it in one little drop into water and
it turns it into fruit punch.
I they looked,
they looked at sort of a Tang rip off that.
Uh,
that spot was amazing.
That little stitches,
that little stitches was a,
the little dark room.
That was amazing.
Unless you are a young mullet haired kid and your brother came to see it for the
first time and you ate shit in front of everyone.
I did my first head over there.
How'd you do have set?
I wasn't that good.
Okay.
Your first site wasn't good.
Pretty fucking terrible.
Talking about this.
I don't know if is Bert Kreischer,
but that would be a great setlist show.
Kind of themed show.
His breakout your first notebooks.
Oh Wow.
That'd be great.
I wish I still had them.
I would love to do that.
It was embarrassing.
I have him.
I got mine too.
Really?
My first one I wrote out my name I wrote out,
hi,
my name is Doug Stanton.
I like,
I wrote every fucking word out.
I have it.
Did you ever practice on a tape recorder before you actually did comedy?
I don't remember doing that.
My Dad had one of those things.
I would try and do like record funny things,
you know,
we had to push down fingers.
Yeah,
yeah.
Like the cassette thing.
Office guys did dictation or whatever to those things.
Yep.
I had the exact same thing.
I tried to make silly a little radio shows.
I didn't try to do that,
but I tried to do standing up in it.
I would try to do my own version of stand up as if I was talking to a crowd and
then I would like play it to a couple of my friends.
Do you think this is funny?
None of them.
They all had the same look like,
oh my God,
what are you doing?
Like if you're a white guy wants to try boxing,
they're like,
oh yeah,
I'm gonna fucking kick everybody's ass bro.
Like there was this,
there was this,
uh,
it's a sense of like,
like sadness and they listened to your comedy.
Like you're fucking,
you're never going to make it.
Like this is terrible.
But the open Mike,
when you're first starting,
you're like throwing anything against the wall that would work.
You know,
I was breaking down into two.
There's two very distinct stages and the beginning of your comedy and the first
stage.
Did you do anything to try to get a laugh?
Shit.
You don't think it's funny.
It's just tools that just hammers and screwdrivers and just hoping to get
something that works.
See monkeys was a phrase.
I thought it was funny.
That's a funny thing.
And build anything around it where I turned it into a sexually transmitted
disease eventually,
but I just wanted to say sea monkeys cause I thought that was funny.
It's a funny word.
Yeah.
There was a bunch of those.
I used to say spatula.
I had a,
I use a prop I used,
I used a prop on my first open mic and I didn't realize it was racist.
I was race and why was it a blind drawn a cross burning I made,
it was a monkey with a fucking jockey outfit on in a basketball uniform.
His hat on backwards.
That's with a boombox in his shoulder.
I had no idea he was attacking him.
Punching none.
Picking cotton in blackface,
chained to a plantation stare.
It was open Mike night.
Sorry.
It's robbing a white man.
Hey Boo man book,
Fat Albert's friend with the hat over his face.
I had no idea it was racist by the way.
I'm wired.
I'm super respectful.
Black people.
No one.
I'm sorry.
What were you saying
something wasn't racist.
I made it an art class.
I started when I was 17.
I made a one of those high school,
uh,
one of those black trace Mr Bill tick.
All the white women were climbing on it.
Why was eating a piece of chicken?
There's no reason it should have taken this long to,
it gets to this
fucking cry.
Welfare checks.
You have his back pocket and have no idea why anybody would take this shit was
racist.
It bell bottoms on an Afro.
That's fucking watermelon is delicious.
I don't know what the problem is.
Sunday night.
Why is everybody so uppity?
They had big lips.
His Urethra.
Yup.
Sorry.
Right.
I had to make it one Megan.
I'm funny saying,
sorry.
Nothing.
Black Guy Joe.
Just try a cigarette.
One cigarette while the store.
I did it with you.
Come on.
I really don't want to hear this story.
Fuck it.
I ain't even tell him.
I never would have fucking told anybody.
You guys clown.
Don't tell anybody on
the Internet.
Yeah,
please.
That's ridiculous.
You guys go off watermelon and your phone.
What was your racist thing?
I'll tell you my first race.
I was a kid.
I didn't,
you know,
whatever.
I didn't know any better.
I was checking,
you know,
you're trying to be funny and uh,
I don't know.
I,
you know,
I wasn't,
I made an art class,
uh,
one of those street signs that the school's cross cause cross crossing and like
I made it art class like you know,
like a black markers and I made it and like,
and I,
and I like yellow poster board.
I cut it,
the s the size,
the shape of the fucking school crossings.
And I said,
come on.
When was the last time you saw two ball headed black kids walking to school
carrying books?
I don't get it.
It was 10.
I was 17.
I was in it.
I mean why is it so it was just,
when did you,
when would you ever see two bedroom flat in the sign had no,
it's the regular street sign.
Yeah.
What did you know?
A school crossing.
So I recreated that exact thing.
So the,
it's black kids.
It was stupid.
I was 17 you know,
it's way more racist is,
I'm so glad I opened up.
I didn't get it.
The signs you get when you're in fucking San Diego.
Oh,
those,
yeah.
The family running across the highway.
It's the dad and the mom and the little girl got married.
By the way,
this is not even the dad,
it's the mom.
Right,
but it's funny that the little kid isn't even running.
The kid is like flying.
They're running and the mom's holding the kid's hand and the kid is like flying
cars.
They're running so fast,
you're supposed to slow down because he's watch out more people seeking a better
life.
Be careful.
They're dangerous people seeking a better life and that's up fucking weird thing
in it.
I mean,
you're right next to it.
You're about as close as humanly possible because the only place I've ever seen
in the world watch out for people running across the highway a couple miles away
from bingo.
What's the name of the signed?
Everyone has like every third house,
like a political sign where I live on the border.
A humanitarian aid is never a crime because people that are fucking decent at
the border where I live and they'll leave water out for people that have tracked
across the desert and leave jugs water.
No,
that's very cool.
And Yeah,
you can get arrested for that,
but somehow you can get a rest of the water.
I don't know how it works,
but yes.
Or aiding them without turning them in or however it works so fast.
The Crystal meth houses to kick in the house has a door of the house that gave a
water to somebody.
They don't,
they don't do that.
Where I live,
I think if you made a dent in northern Mexico,
desert is so fucking just desolate and massive.
If you made it that far to the border,
you should get like a private car waiting for it is ridiculous.
The idea that we're going to keep these people from coming over where there's
jobs just because they were fucking shit out of luck.
[inaudible] here's how you attack the militia man guy saying,
cause they're all family people and Jesus and go,
Hey,
if your kids were fucking Shitty,
would you not try to
make their life better by doing that?
Like as a,
as a father,
anytime you go after their kids and put it on their kids,
they had,
would you not try to make your child's life better by getting to a better place?
If you,
we've really,
if we really believe in humans,
just this,
the concept of human beings,
I really believe that humans are just a,
just a porn bundle of potential.
If you're not a total complete racist where you think that your race is superior
or your superior because of whatever shape you are or color you are.
If you're not that,
then the idea of borders and keeping people that are poor out of places where
they don't have to be poor anymore because there's jobs,
it's ridiculous.
Well,
it's funny because people talk about like all of these,
these,
these immigrants flooding over the border.
I've been down to visit you a couple of times.
It's was driving to El Paso from your place once and there's that one small road
that goes from the Bisbee straight to El Paso and it's right along the border
and there's like army troops out there with camouflage and then there's no
towns.
And then you got,
they got ATV vehicles,
ATC vehicles,
and then they,
the,
uh,
the border patrol guys.
This guy pulled me over,
I'm a white guy driving a car and he goes,
uh,
I saw you were driving away from California.
What?
The five,
I've come to visit you with Florida plates.
What the fuck?
A guy.
It's completely ridiculous.
First of all,
I mean,
they got drug related,
which has nothing to do with immigration,
but you're what you were throwing out still,
almost every argument boils down to overpopulation.
Okay,
well these people will,
everyone will continue to fuck until they have some,
like,
you know,
that's a way to look at it.
But the real issue isn't right now that we don't have enough resources to deal
with the people that are in hand.
The real issue is there's people that have no access to resources.
There's people that they have the resources monopolized by gigantic corporations
and the military industrial complex and there's people that live in poverty
where the places where they live or some of the richest places in the fucking
world,
it's more of a greed issue and the money issue and domination issue than it even
is a resource issue.
If you just took the amount of oil that's coming out of places where the people
are incredibly poor and you just looked at that on the graph and said,
how the fuck is this possible?
How is it possible that the place where these people are just born is just
incredibly rich in natural resources but a company that it doesn't have anything
to do with this area as somehow or another acquired the rights to suck it out of
the ground and the people that work in the factories are incredibly poor.
How is that possible?
That's nothing but cruelty has nothing but people with a shit ton of money
dominating people who don't have that opportunity.
It's nothing but a lack of humanity.
It's not about how many babies you have.
It's not about resources.
It's about cons.
Yes,
it is about resources because there's more people all the time and that's why we
need more resources.
It is,
but it's,
did they do with that money,
if they'd used that money to enrich these people?
It's been proven that when get people into an industrialized setting,
you get people into a nice city.
They have plumbing there,
their amount of children,
they have drops.
Like that's one of the number one concerns about all the people that like
believe in overpopulation.
There's another school of thought amongst like real scholars.
I'd say that the overpopulation exists in rural areas,
third world countries,
a lot of different places.
India,
China,
what have you.
But when places become stabilized and people started having careers and lives,
the number of children they have actually drops.
It drops to like every couple will have like one and a half kids or something
like that,
you know,
per,
per statistic.
So it's not that these people are,
everyone's fucking too much.
People keep going up,
so that's not good.
But you know what?
Right now it's totally sustainable.
There's your proven statistics and that there's actual math of how many people
keep appearing.
It is,
but it's not because look,
humans,
the with you,
I'm with you and scoring people.
I agree with you to a certain,
if we want to go outside and count them to win a bet.
No,
there's plenty of people.
There's more people than ever,
but they're always more,
there is always more.
But right now it's totally sustainable.
And what I'm saying is that industrial situations,
the numbers actually drop.
So just because there's a lot of people today and there's 7 billion people and
next year they might be seven point poverty is thriving.
It is currently,
but it doesn't mean that it has to stay that way once industrialization to set,
this is just science when it comes to population control,
when you industrialize an area that people have less children because when the
people start getting careers,
they have less children.
So even though you might have an area that has a lot of people right now,
if that area improves and the quality of their,
their infrastructure,
their,
their economy,
all these different variables.
Obviously I don't have a dog in this fight,
but once they start doing that,
the number of babies that have actually drops.
So it's a matter of,
in my opinion,
I definitely moved into West Hollywood in 1995 in a rent controlled place.
Brian still lives there.
Parking is way fucking harder.
This is not an impoverished place in West Hollywood.
There's more fucking people.
So there's more people here,
but there's less people in Cleveland,
there's less people in Detroit.
Detroit is fucking half empty now.
Detroit,
you can buy a house for 500 bucks.
I mean,
California is a great spot.
It never rains.
It's fucking 80 years,
80 degrees in February.
Everybody moves here because they want to be famous like Kim Kardashians.
You got me there just cause I'm drinking.
Look,
it makes sense.
There's definitely more people like statistically there's way more people and it
is a problem,
but it's not the number one problem.
The number one problem is the country,
the world,
all the economies,
all of the fucking natural resources are controlled by cons,
by evil cons that have shit,
tons of money and weapons.
That's the number one problem.
This idea that our problem is overpopulation.
If we have less people were going to have a fucking smooth sailing.
That's not real because the people that I know are all people.
The people that I love are all people.
They started out being fucking babies and then they came.
Awesome.
I mean that's,
that's all the people that I know had to start out somewhere as people.
If we want to believe that the human race can carry on and more.
Tom Rhodes and Doug Stan homes and more interesting people can exist that way,
someone's got to make a fucking person.
It doesn't mean that we should all and it doesn't mean there's anything wrong
with not doing.
It.
Ain't anything wrong with doing it,
but that's not our number one fucking problem.
Our number one problem is comments that a gigantic chunk of the population is
controlled by cunts and where to cuts come from consequence from the babies.
So to Comedians,
no strippers,
you know all your favorite movie stars,
they all came from a vagina.
But you know,
you're talking about lifting up societies like,
yeah,
Nigeria,
look out for these people.
Or you think these shell executive oil people would get tired of getting
kidnapped and their refineries getting taken hostage.
You have enough security to prevent most of it.
You know there's,
if you've got enough money,
they don't have the society they have.
You got enough money,
you plan ahead.
You can keep people at bay.
It's fucking to game of Thrones type shit.
It's,
it's pretty simple.
It's just more sophist.
Oh,
here he goes,
thrown his intellect.
You can keep up with game of Thrones.
I got through half of the premiere episode.
I go,
ah,
this is too fucking convoluted for me.
But yeah,
look,
I,
I see both points.
I see your point.
I see,
I see.
Look,
life is,
no matter what,
it's pointless.
I mean,
you live and you die for you,
for any individual.
It's a temporary ride.
But I think that to concentrate entirely on the futility of it all
the saw me now,
have you seen,
uh,
but there's nothing,
but we've seen pervert's guide to ideology.
No,
that guy,
he's like the Slovenia is premiere philosopher.
He's,
he's big in England and he's got this great movie.
It's documentary,
it's called the pervert's guide,
dial geology.
And he breaks down with movies and how we're like,
just mass fed these different ideologies.
And he starts with that movie.
They live Oh yeah.
From 88 where the guy finds the sunglasses and you should,
right.
Yeah.
And He sees the aliens.
He was on the podcast last night.
I did with him.
He's great.
Yeah.
Rodney came around.
Yeah,
he's around.
He does like comedy shows with Steve [inaudible].
Yeah.
He came up on stage.
We were doing a podcast and this guy just starts walking towards us and it
starts walking on stage.
And I was like,
three seconds.
I was about to go,
hey sir,
you can't just,
but then right when I did it,
Tony Hinchcliffe goes,
Rowdy Roddy,
piper,
everyone.
I'm like,
ah Ha.
We had no idea.
He just walked on stage in the middle of outside cats kill Tony.
That's hilarious.
Have you ever seen the video he did with Ari when he came on stage with him and
slammed him?
Was there,
that was weird.
All reach a fear.
Got Body slammed by Rowdy Roddy Piper.
Yeah,
that was awesome.
That was awesome.
That was a naughty show,
right?
Wasn't it?
Yeah.
Sam Tripoli.
Did I miss the end of the physic?
I tried to have my prostate
time to a Tom road so I can start pissing when he talks about Isaac and get it
right.
He's done beat.
You set it all up.
He,
uh,
physics a little creek.
It's tough to say.
Here's our,
that standard DRM on announcing it and here's it.
Right?
Piper,
he Armand her from the
space daze and it was Dana DRM and photography.
So I thought the thumbnail was some dude named Dana that put hot chicks up.
So you'd follow him.
And it wasn't till recently where I've found out and I saw she follows you when
they're like,
oh,
that's really a hot chick.
I thought it was a dude using hot chick.
He took a picture of to try to get me to
follow him.
She's a very nice person that happens to be a hardcore porn star,
but she's a very nice person.
Yeah,
it's very cool.
We did a podcast.
What do you doing?
A couple podcasts,
whether at the Ice House,
but we did one with her at Brian's place.
Tabitha.
Steven seems really cool on Twitter.
She's cool to the point where I'm like,
I don't want you to do this.
I follow you.
You don't have to send me a dirty picture every day.
I think she enjoys it though.
Generally.
No,
but she enjoys it,
but you don't have to do that to me.
You want to say I understand.
I understand,
but you've got to let a whole be a Ho.
It's like from a Willie Geto boys.
I think that when they deep coated the hieroglyphics on the pyramid,
that's what it says,
that it's in a cryptic.
You got to use the Rosetta stone to get it correctly.
Yeah.
That's Rowdy Roddy Piper Banner and Ari Shapiro.
His head off the piano.
Some the ass.
I'm sorta sex thing going on.
You know he's passed at the comedy store.
Rodney Rodney.
Yes.
That's where the comic stories today.
Oh my God.
He beat him with,
Oh yeah.
That's when our,
he's like,
okay,
I gotta get Outta here.
Wow.
He really beat him,
but hey,
they used to
for real,
beat the fuck out of each other.
In those old days of wrestling,
those guys used to cut each other in the Ari Shaffir Rowdy Roddy Piper wars.
No.
The real rowdy Roddy piper wrestling matches Doug.
That's what we're talking about.
That they used to beat the fuck out of.
You didn't even pay attention.
We're just showing the video of Rowdy Roddy Piper beaten Ari Shaffir with a belt
and my,
the guy off the mark right now,
you're a little off the mark.
Rowdy Roddy Piper was just beaten Ari with a belt in this video and we were
saying that they,
that's for him.
That's what the fuck they did.
They used to hit each other with chairs and shit.
They really hit each other.
She's like,
you can get hit with a chair and you can be all right if that's what your job
entails.
Like I know you don't want to clean toilets,
but somebody's got to do it.
That's their job.
I always assumed the wrestler was kind of authentic.
The movie.
Yeah.
It's fairly authentic.
It's fairly,
I'm going to do this to you.
Are you cool with that?
Right.
There was a great,
uh,
Louis Thorough documentary where they,
he went around to all these low level pro rate time.
He's on our level,
Tom.
We go,
hey,
we can talk wrestling.
That's dumb.
He goes,
well,
Louie thorough once said,
yeah,
he's fucking sidestepped on golden
pond.
Then we,
now we're now we're on throw Louis throw.
He goes to these local North Carolina
wrestling matches with these amateur guys and not making any money in there.
Cutting themselves with razor blades and making themselves bleed mid fucking
crazy.
One guy puts Barb wire all over himself and they charge a,
knew each other with barbwire,
beat each other with barbwire sticks and shit.
Like for real,
they're cut.
They're like,
they're all bleeding after
original jackass.
Well,
they really used the theater with jackass guy.
There was a big coke scene and they used to hang around a lot of comedians in
the 80s I remember hanging out with Jake the snake,
and he had the largest bag of cocaine I've ever seen in my life.
Well,
those guys are all medicated.
You saw Oh,
constantly hurt.
You saw that documentary beyond the mat?
No.
What does that fucking,
it's,
it's about,
uh,
wrestlers.
It was fantastic.
Pro Wrestlers.
Yeah.
They would like five different guys.
They had to,
the new guys starting out and then intermediaries and then Jake,
the snake Roberts,
who's now playing an armory in Carney,
Nebraska.
Still fucking,
yeah,
he,
and they're going to meet him up with his daughter that he does.
He never met that he abandoned,
but he used to slam Brian.
That's,
it couldn't break away from the march tables.
So I never met her.
No.
You Start Smoking crack and they get them like on a camera shot through his
motel blinds.
Oh,
I don't want smoking crack.
I'm want to get sad right here.
Oh,
just to please stop playing this fucking nonsense.
Get Sad.
Look,
I get sad when I watch people that are wrestlers and then that was fun that that
was the guy that died and watched the documentary,
but fuck,
it was wicked good.
I want it.
It made me want to do a documentary about all the eighties comedians who thought
they had it made because all of a sudden it's like the oil boom now in North
Dakota where everyone's making $5,000 a week with book jokes to Jews walking to
a bar.
Thank you.
$5,000 Kansas City and where they became fixed,
Dunlop fucking lost a leg and then he's dead like,
but for a minute he was fucking huge.
Not even huge.
He was just rich.
He died
to do was get an evening at the Improv.
If you had a Caroline's comedy hour and an evening with the Improv,
you were good.
And if you had an MTV half hour comedy hour and a Caroline's comedy hour an
evening at the Improv.
Holy Shit.
You were,
you were in one of those USA.
You remember those USA comedy guides?
Yeah,
we,
before the Internet,
they didn't have this induced that
put that out.
Kippy had a two page spread.
Skippy from the facts of loss from the show was the fucking show.
Yeah.
Mark Price.
What was the show?
Facts?
Some family ties,
family ties.
The like Justine Bateman once emailed me and I was starstruck.
She goes,
I think you're brilliant.
I go,
oh,
are you the Justine Bateman that I know from TV and this is not a long time ago.
Did you jerk off while you were s?
No,
I was.
It was like six years ago.
I probably told this story on the Internet.
I love Mallory.
She was,
she was incredible.
That's pretty interesting.
So she decided that she's going to reach out to you?
Yeah,
yeah,
it was.
Did you tell all your friends,
this story takes about three minutes.
Do you have the time for it?
She came to a show,
Garrett Morris opened a comedy club,
the downtown Comedy Club,
or Garrett Morris from senator.
Yeah,
and it was like in a Sushi place in a hotel.
So he played it and Justine Bateman showed up after that email and I'm all
excited.
I'm doing two shows.
Well anyway,
whatever it is,
we get done the show.
She's been there.
Lynn,
shock Croft,
you know,
hedbergs wife and Bingo.
They've been drinking a lot.
So I go to the downstairs bar after the show to meet them and some producer,
friend Hollywood types,
and I'm all like,
hey,
I'm nervous because I'm fucking star struck by Justine Bateman at way too late
of an age to be star struck by Justine Bateman.
Good time to take a piss.
Tom Rose Darya,
Tom Rhodes,
you selfish son of a bitch.
So they're fucked.
A bingo and shock.
Crofters so fucked up.
And they're like spilling the tables and everyone's trying to be polite and
ignore the fucking elephants in the room.
They have a pizza on one of those trays that's being heated from the bottom and
shock.
Krav knocks.
The pizza shop Croft,
her excuse is that she's on a,
uh,
what do you,
what's the Diet where you can't have carbs?
Oh,
fucking sack.
And she's doing the Atkins,
so she's drinking vodka instead of drinking beer,
but she's drinking vodka at the same rate you would drink beer.
So she's so fucked up so quickly and she's knocking shit over and you don't know
what love is.
You know,
and I'm like,
uh,
and I'm distancing myself from my own girlfriend and my friend.
I don't know God.
At one point she knocks their pizza on the ground and gets down on all fours.
Scott,
I don't care.
I'll eat it.
And she's eating pizza off Justine Bateman,
his feet and I'm just trying to make a smiley face and Justine was fucking great
and she knew how to bust balls that she's,
she's making fun with it and being kind of cruel.
Like a comic would skip to the next morning.
Shot Croft wakes up from her blackout going,
Oh my God,
did I make an asshole out of myself in front of that?
Justine Bateman and I go,
you are fucking crawling on all fours like a pig eating pizza off her feet and
without any irony or sarcasm.
Shock Croft goes,
oh my God,
I ate pizza.
I'm not supposed to have
dude,
why are you not telling them on stage?
Because it's not my story.
It's abandoned.
I probably told it a million times out.
A bunch of podcasts deleted off the Internet and please tell on stage.
That's a great guy.
Damn story.
She is so funny.
Oh my God,
I so see carbs.
So she's gluten free,
is that what it is?
Yeah.
Again,
this is like six years ago.
I don't know.
That's fucking hilarious.
Well good on Justin Bateman.
Good for her.
What show was she on?
Family ties.
Emily Michael J.
Fox tech space in Ohio.
He's back benches.
I don't know if you know what Tom Segura has got a fucking 20 minute bit about
the family ties new,
the new Michael J.
Fox show,
brutal,
brutal bit so mean.
So fucking mean fucking rag and the guy with Parkinson's,
I've done four podcasts and 24 hours basically or 36.
So I feel like you got to repeat myself.
But Bert Kreischer I was talking about is Tom Segura is has been on my list of
shit to do to watch cause I've heard about him so much from you,
your podcast and tweets and stuff that and Kreischer said fuck yeah.
You get to see him.
I still have not like pulled up youtube or anything.
Okay.
That's really good man.
Yeah,
he's really good.
We uh,
I,
I met him when I went,
I did the um,
maximum tour with Charlie Murphy,
me and half Ron and Charlie Murphy,
you know Segura Oh,
he's hilarious.
I love it.
Really good.
Every place we went,
they had a new guy opened for us,
you know,
like a,
a local guy or a guy that won like a little contest and he went up in Phoenix.
We did the Hollywood theater,
the same theater with Louie did his last special and it's,
the girl went up and I was like,
Holy Shit,
this guy's good.
He's real.
It was like at all the guy.
We had 22 shows,
so 22 different guys open for us,
but he was the only one that really stood out.
I was like,
he's based,
he's legit.
Podcast is fun too.
Yeah.
It's just a fun guy.
He's just a good guy.
He's like crusher,
you know,
his wife was fucking hilarious to you ever seen Christina Palicki no
show.
Whenever she went up,
Sam triply had this naughty show and uh,
he had all these people on the show and I mean it's all chaos.
It's like,
here's,
there's Tom,
it's like Tom member naked people and people getting beaten by belts and all
this chaos.
And uh,
this woman was beaten,
this guy with a belt and I was thinking,
oh my God,
I can't believe she's got to file this.
Like,
how's she going to fuck on fall?
This is the first time I met her.
She's like real friendly.
And I was like,
Pour Tom's wife,
poor toms wife.
I'm going to go up in front of follow a guy getting beaten by a belt.
She goes up and sleighs and I was like,
Holy Shit.
She's really good.
She's really funny.
It's like finally a husband and wife team where they're both really funny,
which usually like the wives really.
But the husbands
some bitch to just follows her around and tells her how awesome she is.
Yeah.
Or the jokes,
but you can't do it.
And one of the other,
one of the other,
it's either the husband's awesome or the wife's awesome or something.
What are you doing?
That's why their podcasts for the fucking crocodile is her.
When she was on road rules,
she was on road rules,
but she's a really good comic.
Bottom line.
She really good comic.
Funny.
Just a legit legit comedian.
Has nothing to do with the gender or the fact that she's married to a legit
comedian.
It's a rare instance were to legit comedians are hooked up.
Can't come up with another one.
I can't get him.
Well,
I'd love it though cause I,
I'd love that.
The never say it doesn't work.
You know,
people always say,
oh,
don't ever date a comic.
That fucking never works.
You can't say that.
It doesn't,
most of the time it doesn't work,
but doesn't mean it can't work.
It can totally work.
Like Tom and Christina had actually works.
They're both really funny,
but then it's a perfect example of,
come on in history.
There had to be at least an instance of where to funny people that were already
legitimately George Burns and Gracie Allen where they married captain into Neil.
No,
Jim Carrey married Jenny Mccarthy who is hot enough for you to think was funny.
Bone,
Luke Duke.
There's none this fucking Tom and Christina.
That's it.
Never existed.
That's why we need gay marriage.
That's what I'm talking about.
If to really funny guys way you can find too funny women in a room.
But what about if Richard Pryor and George Carlin marry each other at the
greatest gay couple,
the greatest married couple of all time.
Yeah.
Gay Marriage.
They're both gay and he went into comedy.
I bagged gay marriage,
but you're talking interracial and I'm out.
My favorite,
my favorite thing you've ever done outside of your comedy.
He said fucking Bisbee town hall thing that you did where you went up there and
oh,
you didn't see the one where I ate shit the next time.
It was another one.
How did you shit I went up.
This is,
it was the most brutal.
Every comic has had the dream where you go on stage and you can't talk and you
don't know what you're saying in the audiences that happened to me in real life
after I did the one,
I just,
I spouted off at one city hall about,
uh,
you know,
why are you having prayer at a city council?
And that was quick.
And the next time I went when they were actually voting on the referendum for
civil unions,
and I sat in the back listening to all these Christian speak and I just like,
you watch the opening acts and he,
I can riff off of this.
And I developed this bit in my head that was not ready.
And I went up to speak.
And instead of hearing the ladies and gentlemen,
are you ready for your headliner and applause?
I realized it was dead silence.
And I'm,
I'm walking through water and I went up to speak and I lost my breath.
I started to talk and I see the mayor looking at me like,
why are you up here?
What are you doing?
The mayor of Brisbane?
Yeah.
How many people are in Brisbane?
5,000 5,500 make me move there.
I'll make,
I'll become the man.
I just,
everything that should have everything that I thought about listening to a bunch
of speakers.
Is it live?
Is that the video?
Is this the exact change?
Is this it?
Obviously we have enough people in the room to fight on my behalf.
I don't have to be here.
There was rumors of buses of churches that we're going to show up and filibuster
this.
So we felt we could,
no,
this is not the breakdown.
There was the next,
the next city council meeting.
I saw this one.
I fell apart where I,
I,
I'm
like,
I'm talking to a cop with a dead hooker in my trunk and I,
and then and then all the eyes are getting worse and then I start flop sweating
and I'd go,
Hey,
this is why I'm going to default lines.
This is why normally drink when I am Rosa parks in the,
and I had to leave in shame knowing that the fucking mayor and one of the
councilmen and the rest of my friends have seen this and they're coming to my
house and I'm like,
the only I have to leave.
BSB coming to your house.
They,
we would party over there and party with your hair.
Yeah,
man.
Yeah.
The mirror is cool.
I met her about a year old.
How would you panic then if you just went into a fucking pen like I had all this
stuff that I know in my head is a comedy bit that I could do but going wasn't
done yet.
No.
Going up to a bunch of people that are angry and don't want to see me and don't
know.
You got to always bring a least a little bit of your own audience,
but I did.
I had my friends there,
which made it worse.
I have no idea.
It was,
he's a dream that you have where you don't know what the fuck you're doing on
stage and you wake up going,
oh,
fucking thank God.
That was just a dream,
but it was real and it was really to this day,
I see people that were at that city council meeting and I,
I go,
I should kill myself.
You hang your head.
And Shay was,
fuck,
how long ago?
Last year,
dude,
we need to change this and you got to move to a new town.
We didn't move this.
No,
we need to find clean out the town.
Everybody I've seen that we need to kill him.
It's all of those.
That's what I thought.
Yeah.
That's actually said that on stage.
No.
Last week I went up and city council doing yourself.
Not In redeem us.
I didn't kill,
but I went up and said,
hey listen,
we're having a party.
You know I want to talk about noise complaints.
A city council meeting.
You went up and said,
hey,
listen,
we're having a party.
No.
I said,
hey,
listen,
I want to talk about noise complaints.
You know what?
There's neighbors that make noise complaints and you're going to make a lot on
May 25th wherever the party out of respect for a whiskey girl in a nowhere man
who died between a six and 10:00 PM you know what?
Don't call the cops to show up.
Bring some food.
Did you run in a town?
Why don't you run for mayor?
I,
well,
first of all,
when I could,
when I could help you,
but it's uh,
you'd have to show up and it pays $386 a month and an annual and money and all
the people that don't know you.
I hope you will hate you safely.
No,
no.
We'll get rid of them.
Don't move.
No.
How much do you think their houses are worth?
Here's,
here's the reality.
Here's the reality.
If they really have their shit together,
would they be living in Bisbee?
Most likely no,
but that's their world.
Just,
you don't show me people in their move people to town,
Doug,
Stan hope they'd start buying up all these houses of these malcontents who are
upset that you're the new mayor.
When you're on the road,
Jones do your show style.
Let's say there's 500 people at the show at the end of the night,
the staff or your only friends,
you don't fuck with the staff.
I live with the staff.
I live with a small,
tiny amount of people and you're going to see them at Safeway every day and if
you fuck up what they think is important,
meaning city politics in Bisbee,
I don't want to see those.
It's the same reason you wouldn't work a cruise ship because if you suck,
you're going to have to see those same people at the buffet and the Lido deck
and shuffleboard for another week.
I see your point.
I wouldn't work cruise ship because I don't want to be in a boat in the middle
of the fucking ocean trapped with a bunch of people,
but I see your point like if you bomb,
don't be mayors.
It would be fuck Hunter Thompson running for sheriff of a Woody Creek.
If you fucking,
if you ran for mayor of Bisbee and actually one,
it might be the greatest victory that our generation has ever had.
We have a great mayor.
Listen Dude,
let live the great mayors.
Great.
He'll work for you.
This is my thoughts.
You can,
you could take over Bisbee and then from you taking over Bisbee.
We just start moving people in.
Just start.
People will fuck this place.
It's going to shit.
Standups don't cook.
They sell the house.
Cool people buy it.
I want to be near stand up.
Next thing you know,
you got to fucking town filled with Doug's Stan hope fans.
I tell you I,
whenever I visit you,
do you know why I give out my address on your podcast?
Just trying to do the van Dyke Street,
Arizona eight five six Oh three let me repeat to 12 van Dyke Street.
Bisbee Arizona.
Eight five six oh three mail packages to us.
I can give that out because I can't get my own friends,
namely Joe Rogan to even visit me much less.
How that would be happy.
I'd be happy to visit you.
I'd be happy to have is.
You would be.
I haven't done it,
but I would be happy to visit you.
You're going to buy the cave house.
I would like to buy that house,
but then you
fucked up.
Now everybody knows the fucking cave house where I'm going to be known about the
cave house.
It's been five is I the cave house?
That's a different thing because you just said bother airbnb fucked me up.
You fucked up my cave house dreams right there by disclosure by in voluntary
disclosure.
You fucked up my cave house.
Dream House has been in so many magazine.
We just need guns and fences and shit.
We have guns.
Hire Mexicans.
My think that you could run that town,
Dude,
I think you're already running that town.
You already own any real estate.
Have you seen windy city heat?
Great show.
That's what we're looking at.
Fine is to not run for mayor but runs someone for mayor.
That's okay.
Now I like how you said now I like how you thinking now.
Now I like what you're thinking.
We need to do is just,
there's a lot of people that just really are not totally buying the whole future
Bisbee experience.
We need to get them to start selling,
you know,
it's like a reverse blockbusting let them know,
look gentrify.
Bisbee I already have a guy that's made the logo.
It's the communist fist with a Rolex hill central five Bisbee that's your
version of the Gonzo fucking two thumbed,
uh,
holding the payoti button.
Gentrify.
Bisbee we're in communist lettering to you make it very attractive.
Make moving to the middle of nowhere next to them.
Cool town.
I couldn't do it.
No,
you have to have the fucking you.
You need shit around you.
What do I need to write?
Good.
I'm good.
Like just laying in the Hammock,
but I'm going to actually have a hammock.
I lived in the mountains of Colorado for a while,
for about two months and fucking fled back here.
No,
it was three months,
but the only my wife got pregnant.
You can't live up there if you're pregnant.
The point is,
but you can't.
You are like a tail.
You have to do a show before the giant show.
You have to have a big show before the giant show.
I understand it.
I'm not down downing you.
What does that mean,
the big show for the giant show?
Well you go to do UFC and then you do a big theater show before you do the
monstrous bucking UFC show and yeah,
you thrive on that kind of attention.
I,
I'm terrified by it.
When you brought me to UFC,
I've never been more scared.
Even with you,
just stay with me.
Get a picture of nick.
Fuck.
Fuck you.
Hollywood.
That's my UFC experience in a nutshell.
Fuck you,
Hollywood.
Me Walking through a crowd.
Joe,
you got me tickets to the staple center a couple of years ago and I had never
been to UFC and I absolutely loved it.
Uh,
just,
just transformed cause I was a real boxing fan purist and I absolutely fell in
love with it.
But the seats were like way up in the top of the arena and some guy that was
sitting in my seat and I mentioned a guy was in my seat.
I showed him the ticket and I started talking to the guy,
he was like the next seat over
and I was so high up and I had mentioned that Joe Rogan had gotten me the
tickets and the guy turns to me.
He goes,
I thought you were better friends because they were so high up.
They were like,
how high up were they were pretty high.
Did you get the tickets really last minute or something?
Uh,
you must be probably a couple of days before.
That's the problem.
It was probably sold out.
That's all I could get.
You fucking lazy.
Have Brian,
how many times you've been on the floor?
Uh,
almost every time was on the floor or get in touch with me.
Stand ups on the floor.
Right.
Had you on the floor.
You can't Holler at me two days before roads is probably based on that racist
bit.
You do that fucking watermelon.
I should have kept that a secret soldier.
That was a black fighter headlining.
Oh.
Oh God.
Dude,
if you ever want to go,
just ask me.
Don't think you'd have to drop hints on a podcast.
Jesus Christ.
I get you better seats,
Bill Cosby.
Fuck yeah,
we're going to go.
We're going to go see bill Cosby if you want to go.
Me,
I'm telling you,
I keep hearing these really fucking funny.
I keep hearing from a bunch of people,
but he tells these long really funny storytelling bits.
I heard it from bill burr.
I heard it from a Ian Edwards hurted bill Cosby.
I heard it from Chris Rock.
I heard it from a bunch of fucking people that Cosby's fucking hilarious.
Yeah,
I heard the same thing.
I keep hearing it,
man.
I heard it from a due to random dude,
it doesn't even do comedy in Austin.
He goes,
you know what really fucking surprised me.
my friends took me out to see bill Cosby and I was like,
I don't want to go see bill Cosby man.
And he's like 80 years old.
What the fuck am I going to get out of this?
He goes,
dude,
I was fucking crying laughing.
He goes,
for the first five minutes you go,
what am I getting into?
Cause he doesn't have an opening act.
He just goes out there and he starts talking over the first five minutes.
It takes a while to build up and he goes like,
I'm like,
what am I doing?
Like what?
Oh my God,
what am I fucking sitting through?
How long is this going to be?
He goes,
then you start,
fuck it.
He starts tying things together.
You start fucking laughing and then it goes deeper and deeper.
Apparently he's been touring like you go look at his schedule,
he's fucking touring a lot and you look at his schedule.
I saw him working out a lot of that shit at the comedy cellar.
He joking.
Yeah.
Jay doesn't work it out at all.
He does it on stage but he's working at [inaudible].
Bill Cosby,
like bumping someone at the comedy cellar at midnight and work out some new
shit.
Still doing to theater shows a night in some places.
I mean he's doing a lot of shows and I think always get all those illegitimate
kids to take care of.
He has also had a few lawsuits.
Yeah,
rape sounds awesome.
Yeah.
Beats whatever between the law,
like the same language and pop between the lengthy phone calls to black comics
about how they're ruining the fucking yes.
Right.
Listen,
he's 100%.
He's flawed.
He's definitely flawed.
But my idea of it is not to connect him to what the art form that I appreciate.
Like I appreciate guys like you guys like you Diaz.
I understand.
I don't like what he,
I don't like clean comedy.
Donald Sterling
needs this same fucking decency.
Hey,
that's a old feeble fucking dude that America's up in arms about rather than the
justice system,
which is really abusively racist.
Oh yeah.
Yo Bill Cosby.
Donald Sterling tour together.
MMM.
Okay.
I see your point.
Um,
um,
I'm not,
I switch headphones with Tom Rhodes,
so it looks like he said that.
Yeah.
I'm not in support of anything that,
uh,
the Donald Sterling or bill Cosby said,
but I think that it's tough to ignore Cosby as a craftsman and sterling's not
that funny.
And I think sterling is pretty funny when he's trying to bang a 20 year old and
he's fucking 81.
I think it's funny that he pulls it off,
you know,
and he's got a buy.
Everybody's like,
oh my God,
he bought her a Bentley and a Ferrari.
You have to buy him a Bentley and a Ferrari.
If you have $1 billion,
a Bentley and a Ferrari.
It's like buying a chicken necklace you buy or something pretty and she sucks
your Dick.
And then if you're lucky,
she'll do it again in six months,
but he shouldn't have missed a payment.
If you're a millionaire guy and you're banging some psycho side policy,
uh,
you know,
make sure they got the payment.
You know what happens is these guys get fucking greedy and they don't realize
how much $1 billion really is.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I've been that guy.
You can give a chick like I've been that guy where you're so desperate for a
chick not to leave you.
That's out of your league.
Yeah.
You start talking racial shit to make her feel uncomfortable.
That's why this is so much worse.
Shit.
That's what he did.
He said some racial shit to make her feel uncomfortable,
man.
You know?
I mean,
I think that's what happened and that's what he said happened.
I think he's just an asshole.
Just an old ass.
And he didn't know that he was being recorded.
Cherry,
she came on CNN like two days late because I'm his silly rabbit.
Did you see that?
No,
she,
she went like two days later she was,
gee,
I miss,
I'm his silly rabbit is a view of race that might be inappropriate to someone.
A racist doesn't hire black general managers and coaches like that.
Yeah.
He's a fucking clansmen is real racism in the world.
Sports people are not your fucking,
yeah.
Well the one thing,
it wasn't talked about those of morality.
Did he say it in his own house?
I mean,
you should be able to say whatever you want and your own house.
Right?
Apparently that's what's kind of Orwellian about it.
But they never said where it was recorded.
Well,
why would,
do you know,
why would he bring the site pussy niggers over?
You know what?
My team's going to be all white.
Well,
apparently here please.
He said,
fuck,
go ahead and fuck black guys.
Michael.
Not Michael Jordan,
Magic Johnson,
Magic Johnson is that,
you know what?
Feed them.
Fuck them.
I don't care.
Just please don't put pictures on Instagram if that's racist.
Well,
the idea is that it's racist because this is great position of power.
People keep contacting me.
God,
you're fucking a black guy.
It's the culture.
They calm.
Did you,
Donald,
did you really buy that broad?
You bought her a Ferrari and look at it and dig into big,
you know that the magic magic
magic is just constantly fucking is broad and you're buying a Rolls Royce car.
She's taking pictures.
You know what?
Magic butter,
butter Dick Sandwich.
That's what he bought.
I have a black girlfriend and I said,
it's okay if you flunk.
Fuck another black guy.
Just don't put pictures on the Internet.
So people fuck with me.
That's a racist.
Now that is a racist.
The guy with a black girlfriend that he's cheating on his wife with saying,
you can fuck other black guys.
Just don't put it on the Internet.
That's racism.
Um,
listen,
he doesn't know any better.
These are quotes.
He doesn't know any better.
Doug Stanhope.
He doesn't know any better than to not fuck a black girl.
If you're a racist,
you're a racist,
Donald.
You get it wrong.
You don't fuck black girls and you don't say it's okay to fuck other black guys
as long as you don't put it on the,
did you see that shit?
We talked last time we talked about it.
We brought up the fact that maybe he had Alzheimer's or something like that.
That's what they're trying to say now that he has the early stage.
Isn't he forgot that he's dating a black girl?
No.
Well that's the whole reason why the whole recording was being done the first
place.
He can't remember the things he said.
So part of her job,
she actually works for him.
Part of her job is that she's supposed to record these conversations so that he
can talk about things and she could bring it up what he's already talked about.
So he knows what he said.
Apparently he's like going meant right.
And then so she releases the tapes.
What sterling thinks.
That's what she said.
He said the opposite.
Evidently I read the transcript because I don't have cable at my Airbnb,
but my girlfriend pissed your bed so we're even,
it didn't hit the mattress.
I think it's a sad state.
It's a sad state when you want to fucking shit on an old man who is alone in his
home and everybody's going off on him.
Everybody you just took up for him.
He's got all this money.
He's an old man that wants to get his head when he says stupid shit being led
off fucking death row only because of the innocence project clearing their name
because they were black.
They were convicted of Shit and spending 20 years in prison,
the justice system,
fucking cops shooting black kids because they thought they had a gun and that's
not blown up in the news.
That's not trending on Twitter of fucking old feeble man.
Gone Fuck Michael Jordan or Magic Johnson.
No,
I couldn't agree more.
I mean obviously in in perspective,
but the idea is of course we're paying attention.
This guy because he's a billionaire and because he owns a gigantic sports and he
also made a shit fuck ton of money off of black people and apparently he's not
happy about black people banging his side piece.
You know,
the whole thing is hilarious that it's so mild.
The things that he said,
hold on,
hold on a second.
Whether it's racist or not so mild in the context that he said it in the comfort
of his own home,
there was no racial slurs,
there was nothing defamatory.
There's no,
the less than us,
they're not white.
They're not us.
I heard that.
I think Elan,
Jerry West the money to buy the Lakers,
so that guy singlehandedly is responsible for basketball in Los Angeles.
Well,
he's a fucking
rich dude.
He's super successful,
but he's a cunt.
He's been a cut forever.
He's been racially discriminating against people that lived in his properties,
but so have a million other people.
He's,
he was 60 when the internet came out.
I'm not sticking up for the guy.
He ain't a great guy.
I'm not.
He's not a perfect example of what an 80 year old person has learned from the
lifetime.
Stakes can be.
He's not.
He's an old billionaire.
He wanted to get his dick sucked by some crazy bitch.
We talked a lot of shit and we found out about it because it got out.
It was a private thing.
How many people out there have that grandfather slash uncle slash guy that you
listened to him at Thanksgiving dinner?
Say Way worse shit with like you know the epithets saying nigger and spic and
everything and y'all just go.
Do you want some more?
A butternut squash uncle Harry especially,
but the thing is everything's going to be recorded.
There's just recording devices everywhere you can.
What's an example of what we're learning?
We're learning or Wellington.
We're going to have to just be constantly aware of what we're saying.
Stop.
Please get out of my fucking head.
All right,
closer.
Drop the headphones and leave.
Well your volunteer
terribly doing that by doing something like this right now,
you're free for three hours.
You've given up your thoughts.
You know,
I think there's not going to be any secrets.
I think the idea,
I think I'm going to give you one further.
There's not going to be any money because money is information and money right
now is just ones and Zeros on a fucking website somewhere.
I mean,
that's what bitcoin is going to be.
That's what the money essentially that we have now.
It's not backed by gold.
That's what it is.
The thing of secrecy will.
Yeah,
it's a bit of,
I've never done enough hallucinogens to work out,
but the fact that it's calling,
yeah.
The fact that you will never have a private thought.
Yeah.
There's not going to be any private inner voice,
but you know what that means.
We,
we,
we want to think of it as like everything that we experience in our lifetime is
like a static thing then has to stay like this,
but it never does.
It never has from the moment that some fucking weird little sneaky little
multi-celled thing crawled out of the ocean.
It's never been the same.
Everything keeps changing.
It's going to keep changing.
And what we're doing right now,
which we're figuring out new ways to not be able to hide shit,
not be able to,
to hide ideas,
not be able to hide the very thoughts and your own fucking mind,
not just what you say when you're trying to bang your side piece and she's
recording you besides your piece.
Your mind is,
that's the new coin term because of Donald Sterling.
It's not the no,
that's been around for ever.
It's caught side bitch and it's no,
that's only in your shortfalls are so rude.
He's up massage.
I know.
Um,
he got some porn star Pussy at some point in all of a sudden this is just
indicative of some greater trend that's going on and that greater trend is the
access to information.
That's what it is.
It's the information,
whether it's information like the idea that what you say in a room,
it's just like there's an echo and it dies off so I got to die off anymore.
There's not going to be an echo is going to be a recording and it's going to
change.
The very dimension that you exist in the very world that you interface with is a
completely different world now and it's because the very things that come out of
your mouth and no longer temporary then now resourceful there,
none of than than,
than every searchable.
You can go back and find them.
You put them in a bank,
you hold on to them,
you have amount of phone,
you have them in a,
in a database and Utah because the NSA has collected all your emails.
As long as there's celebrity,
as long as there's a Donald Sterling,
that doesn't matter.
Versus the cop who was caught on tape,
you know,
hitting a fucking guy with this baton.
But they're getting in trouble too.
I mean the guy who just shot that 83 year old lady,
the 83 year old,
93 93 crazy lady had a gun screaming and young guy came in and just unloaded on
are just pumped a fucking ton of bullets into her and they're like,
well,
every week,
like,
what are you doing?
You didn't just shoot.
The old lady wants you shot her,
shot a fucking dozen bullets in her direction or something crazy like that.
I mean,
it's not,
it is every week and it doesn't make sense and it's not fair and that is to be
an exposed,
not as much as the,
the people like the Donald Sterling's,
but enough that you see a trend.
If you just looked at it completely objectively outside the ideas of social
justice,
they'll just look at it like,
yeah,
we'll look at it like a a like a scientific observation.
If you look at it like that,
you go,
well yeah,
Mel Gibson got fucked over by some crazy Khan,
Donald Sterling.
He's an old man,
raped by a pack a nigger and turn in your fucking sag card because they take it
into account that he's a fucking entertainer.
And they gave him a little bit slack.
But stepping outside of the,
the idea of justice give black people hundreds of millions of dollars.
You're right,
Donald Sterling who goes,
please don't quantify who's better.
I don't think you should quantify who's better.
I think what I look at it on it.
I tried to not think of myself being connected.
What would I do if I was an old crazy guy like Donald sterling or Mel Gibson?
I go,
what's going on?
What's going on is just not gonna be any secrets.
Like you better get used to it.
Cause it's,
it's,
it's slowly happens with a,
a TMZ tape that the fucking mistress of,
uh,
Donald Sterling releases or Mel Gibson's crazy rants,
his racist rant at a cop or you know,
whatever.
But when
you're sitting in a cubicle and you went on a date with another guy in the
office and you're typing on Facebook going,
he's fucking,
he was kind of Nice,
but he's filthy and he's as bad breath and he chews with his mouth open.
All of a sudden,
yeah,
now you're,
you're reading that on Facebook about you.
It's no longer TMZ about some celebrity.
Now you're finding out the truth about how someone feels about you on the
Internet and you go,
Oh,
oh my God.
That's how people feel about me.
I'm,
I'm just a guy in another cubicle.
Yeah.
People find out shit about you without being famous.
You're not famous,
but you read,
Oh,
this is,
my cousin just said this about me and social networking and now I know.
Yeah.
No one has any secrets.
Well,
pull effect.
I mean,
right now it's hidden in the celebrities first,
but it's going to,
it's going to go deeper and deeper into the culture.
This is no getting around it,
man.
It's like what we're experiencing now is not going to be with the future is the
future is gonna be,
we're gonna be able to read each other's fucking minds.
They're really close to it.
They're coming up with technology on a day to day basis.
That is establishing the,
the very steps to take to not just be able to send each other pictures or emails
on a phone,
but be able to do it mind a mind that's there.
They're working on that.
That's not,
it's not like an impossibility.
That's it's an inevitability.
It's just a matter of how long it's going to take for the technology becomes
viable.
They're working on it so they're not going to,
unless we get hit by an asteroid or invaded by aliens,
we blow each other up in a nuclear war.
It's common.
Worst fear about reincarnation as I go,
I'll be
dead before that happens.
Oh wait,
I'll come back.
Jesus.
Well,
not only that,
what if they come up with something that fucking regenerates you?
What did they come up with?
Something like this mouse thing where they are injecting young mice blood into
these mice and making the mice regenerate and they're actually regenerating
brain tissue and reversing the signs of aging.
This is like legitimate scientific experiments they're doing on mice where
they're showing that this is a,
a potential like thing that might work on all mammals mind not just only work on
mice and mice be something to do with anything.
I saw this on Sullivan and son.
Hey,
speaking of,
ah,
that's you.
Would you just assume like,
I'd rather not,
I'd rather fucking go out and blaze a camels was just keep it bucket.
He's a,
Peter gave you an opening,
you said before the show,
you need to miss a week to get ahold of them.
They're fucking president swell up.
They have the very small little bladder.
It's like a coin purse for a child.
You know what?
I spent so much time dealing with my prostate,
one on one,
one on one with two fingers or one.
I mean,
when he's in a glove or whatever dog you snip your nails,
do you file down the edges or you just fucking crazy?
It's going.
They're ragged with a coke nail.
One of those fucking big ones from Dracula.
That's a silver with a tip on the end.
I just tear
up the inside of your were assholes.
Find my prostate and to a world of pain,
hell raisers style,
ah,
that lasts Soliloquy of mine.
Laughs evidently,
evidently didn't make sense to you.
That was the eye roll.
No reason I don't do podcasts by myself.
It makes sense.
That makes sense.
Eventually Joe Rogan has to frown on me and I go,
hey,
that's an hour.
Neither one of us,
neither one of us are.
I mean there's no,
no right or wrong.
We're both making sense.
You know?
It's like there's a bunch of different points to this whole thing.
You're absolutely right that it's the one of the most minor forms of racism
ever,
where people having this massive amounts of outrage,
but people always have mass amounts of black girl,
but people have massive amounts that were outraged at anything a billionaire
does,
especially if that building,
they have a bunch of mots of outrage at what CNN tells him to be outraged.
That's too,
that's true too,
but the,
this is one of those things where if you have a billionaire who owns a bunch of
black people's contracts,
he owns a bunch of thank God.
There was a parentheses.
Yeah,
sweet.
I go,
I want to buy the La Clippers but have the money,
but I think it would be racist to buy just one
he owns.
I mean he owns Doug Stanhope.
If you own a team,
do you own
contracts?
I mean,
how do you own it?
I mean you own,
you're essentially,
you own the business.
It's employing x amount of black people.
Interesting that that guy is this.
To see how the 1% lives,
you know that this guy can like by his Chica Ferrari,
like he doesn't care that it's,
you know,
he loses 2.5 million.
What is,
he looks at people like plantation a Chris,
the Chris rock bit was a,
there's a difference between rich and wealthy.
Shaq is rich.
The guy that writes the signs,
shacks check is welcome.
That's a great,
that's a great bit.
I don't even,
you think
we could wrap our heads around the idea of the 1% they're the real Rockefeller
type money,
you know,
that's been in their circulation of their family for fucking generation after
generation.
I think it's so insane.
It's so decadent.
I mean the reason why we have these ideas about like skull and crossbones,
the nepotism that these family fucking groups that get handed down.
My son will be in his colon crossbones as well.
They all get together and they put on diapers and paddle each other and suck
each other's dicks and take Polaroids of it,
put it in a vault in the middle of fucking Yale,
somewhere deep in the dungeon.
I mean,
that's because these guys have been in control of some ridiculous thing that
they should have never had the power to wrap their fucking greedy little fingers
around billions and billions and billions of dollars with no work at all.
They were born into it and they're born into this and they're like,
this is our legacy.
We have to,
it happens on every
level of society.
Yup.
It does.
Whenever someone has like a real solid,
you're a cab batcher and you're going to give your friend that drinks with you,
the better fucking fair before everyone fucking does that.
Yeah,
but that's like a friendship thing.
There's a difference between that.
That is a theory.
Naysayers,
conspiracy theories happen on in this fucking room.
People conspire against each other on some level,
but on this guy's level,
why is it such a surprise to people that he looks at it like a plantation
workers?
That these are,
you know,
his property.
I think way a lot of billionaires have that attitude that bees on the ranch,
the same way you bring openers in case Joey Diaz doesn't show up.
Hey,
you know what?
You're lower than Joey Diaz,
but you're year for a reason.
That's the same kind of theory as,
hey,
you work for me.
Why?
Wait a minute.
Hang on someone else.
Make that make sense.
Cause that does,
hold on a second.
You're saying to a guy that you're less than Jody is.
That's the same as the Donald's.
You're fucking openers.
You're a plantation owner.
You own your own
to the extent that Donald Sterling does.
Oh,
I see.
I'm feel,
I feel terrible now.
Oh No,
no.
I'm saying he shouldn't feel terrible and he's paying them mother fuckers old
cons.
He's like,
he's born in the era of the fights.
When Duncan Trussell you behind your back.
It was a great show and I should have been Joey Diaz the whole time.
Oh,
that's funny.
John D Rockefeller is worth 340 billion.
Not million billion dollars.
That's the number one richest American.
The mom,
that's guy's dead.
That's not helping this family.
But John D Rockefeller,
when did he die?
He died in 1937 that's the point.
No one cares.
It's such a,
Barb can say that.
Go see with you said Tom Rhodes was talking to somebody a couple weeks ago and
every time I mentioned someone's name,
the entertainer,
the guy who was,
he was on the Internet and I think it's like net worth.com you can punch in
anybody's name and it says what their net worth is
to see if it's accurate.
Wait a minute,
who the fuck do you talk to that does that.
If they do that,
stop talking to her and talks about it all the time like,
well,
why?
First of all,
have you checked it?
Well,
no.
Why would I keep right now and see if it's close?
I know how off by a million.
I have my cousins,
I'm not even going to,
my cousin's a cop in Florida and I got to drive,
but to see if it's accurate.
Why did the substantiated,
Oh,
who cares?
The point is not whether or not it's accurate.
My point is who the fuck?
You tell a guy,
a guys who you're talking about and the guy immediately goes and checks his
worth,
tell you,
who cares,
the moron.
Do you want
me to show or maybe Steve Viano cares and her name's Vanessa.
Stop Saying v by the way,
it's not even her name.
Okay.
It's a fake name.
She got a bunch of aliases the way,
but she branded herself as v Steve Yano.
Fuck you.
You're a gold digging cunt.
But we'll go with Vanessa.
Hey,
she's a nice girl who has something to offer.
Look,
she's not carrying logs.
She's not being a fucking woodcutter for the the mill.
Those guys don't want to be there either.
She's sucking old rich Guy Dick.
She might start [inaudible] a scam,
but when you get busted at it,
just say,
yeah,
listen to my opinion is a noble profession that's been around longer than any
other profession.
She is going to inspire a lot of other young girls to get them all the time when
it looked like it's all about what they're worth.
Look,
if he was George Clooney,
that check would be fucking them all the time,
but he's not.
He's an 81 year old bag of meat.
He's an old wrinkly coins sack filled with flesh and some shitty hollow chicken
bones that barely carry his old wounded hips around his fucking million dollar
mansion.
He's an old fuck.
Okay.
And she fucks him when she has to fuck him and no more,
no less.
And that's what the market dictates.
Okay.
If it was George Clooney,
if it was chocolate Dell,
chuck the Dellwood fucker anytime he wanted to,
cause he's an animal and he's alive and he's still a man.
This is a guy who's barely clinging onto the very cellular existence that he
maintains in this dimension.
His body's ready to tap the fuck out.
So when she fucks him is when she fucks him.
And that's the deal.
You buy the Bentley,
you pay the Ferrari,
you take your fucking ride.
And that's how the market set.
Uh hmm.
There's nothing wrong when she's doing,
there's nothing wrong with he's doing either.
Both of them are doing fine work,
work.
And then when you fucking tape record that guy for no reason,
just to fuck him over,
I don't think she tape recorded him to fuck him over.
What I understand about this.
The story is she let the tape recording out to fuck him over,
but part of her job was to tape record and because
come on,
let it out.
And then when she went on CNN like two days later and she was on there or no,
no,
I'm sorry.
She did a fucking Barbara Walters interview.
She's going to inspire young girls all over America to be fucking old guys.
He comes out on on Barbara Walters and she says,
I'm Mister Sterling's right arm,
right hand man.
Is that you whore?
You have one line we've taught you to say to cover the woodshed.
You on this one head,
one fucking line.
She was supposed to say for the news fucking sound bite and she fucked it up.
Are you saying you did not look at that chick for a fraction of a second and
summer up completely knowing what a horrible La Gold digger,
whatever label you,
it's fishing him the whole time.
Well,
no doubt.
My old bit about Anna Nicole Smith and her fucking husband,
j Howard Marshall,
that billionaire guy,
we all,
everybody was like,
no,
but it's the idea is that of course that's the deal.
You're in 90 fucking years old.
That girls young.
That's the deal.
She took it a step beyond the deal.
I can put Andy Andrews to in the mix.
She's to the point where you go,
okay,
you stepped over the fucking man boundary of what the line is.
You don't tape me and then put that out there for no reason just to make me look
like an asshole after the fact.
Yes,
I agree with you.
I think that she is a bad person,
no doubt about it and no and no doubt about it,
but also he's a bad person and who knows what fucking chaos she grew up with and
who knows what fucking shit he said that she didn't record.
Who knows what the fuck they're relationship is.
But what I know is that like vultures circling,
carrying this is all over the news.
I mean this is,
we're in the middle of two fucking wars.
You know,
Russia is invading the Ukraine.
We got all kinds of chaos over the world and everybody's focusing on nonsense
and the alluding us.
Yeah,
it's the three [inaudible] about the Ukraine.
Clean had talking about legitimate social commentators.
In this day and age,
we count as legitimate social commentators.
We're doing our job to point out the,
the fruitlessness of this pursuit.
Go out tomorrow and do something nice for someone you don't know.
That's my point in fucking people have a barbecue.
Yeah.
Don't care.
Don't even talk about Donald Sterling by that cave house in Bisbee so I don't
move in.
Move in and take five acres.
If we could get 52 buyers one week a year,
that's what I'm talking about.
A fucking time.
Share in a cave and been in for a week and call it the mushroom palace when just
go to eat mushrooms and then just rent it out.
We can make a legit deal.
The police department badge.
Come on,
we can make it.
I have to.
But you smoke cigarettes for three hours.
What are you talking about?
I don't look,
we can make a legitimate deal or the show that's production.
If we can make a legitimate deal with the local government,
you know,
somebody we know becomes mayor and work something out.
Uh,
some sort of an audit shamonic retreat down in Bisbee,
Arizona may or you're a target.
We have a nice little underground tunnel somewhere near a tail.
Somebody who has a case.
I told you off the air stories,
I told you three of them about how great Bisbee is.
And I'll tell you the fourth wouldn't have to worry off.
This is what we do.
We get someone on your death pool to be the mayor.
And we were placing him with the most likely candidate every year.
So we constantly celebrities and dying off.
Not now.
But you had fucking Jake Lamata and your living room.
Dude.
I saw the picture.
Not dead yet.
That's what I'm talking about.
Jake Lamata as mayor of the busy bee.
You follow what I'm saying?
It's perfect.
And then who's his vice president?
Wayne Newton.
Shit.
Somebody else's ready to fucking go.
We've talked about it.
You need to,
it's not the mayor Johnny,
Johnny Depp.
Is that a real Johnny Depp?
Who's that guy we are?
Whatever,
whatever.
I'll tell you another time.
Oh Shit.
It's a real tough shit.
Okay,
so forget about Johnny Depp Party in your house.
What's a,
you know,
there's people that we could have that could be a,
a mayoral candidates work something.
Now we've got a little utopia going on here,
but it's a little bit of a shell game.
It's a bit of a shell game right now to keep it moving.
It's utopia for me.
Maybe you move in all the fucking vultures.
Follow you.
I like,
I was so nice to move to and,
and ruined the neighborhood,
but he started crossfit and
sandbags.
They'll turn their blood mix ionize water and fucking getting vampire blood.
Yeah.
Kettle Bell Boulevard.
I liked the idea was just glorious.
I burn the other night.
It's a great guy.
I heard that.
Oh,
Tom Rose Byrne.
I'm at a place now where I met so many comics over the years and I've been kind
of away from them for 10 years that I met Steve Byrne and I assumed I knew him
and he was like,
oh so nice to meet you.
And I'm like,
I don't,
we already know each other because you're so familiar.
And I was in a drunken state.
Tom Saw me there.
This fucking story just got shady,
right?
I'm not buying this at all.
Well it's like Amy Schumer.
I don't know if I assume I've met her cause she looks familiar and now she's
famous.
So I just assume we probably met at a festival somewhere cause she got famous on
the sneak tip early after me,
after my career.
She was so I go,
we probably met at Montreal.
So Steve Byrne,
he's like,
no,
I've never met you.
And I'm like,
ah,
maybe I'm just drunk.
I thought I did.
So I shit,
I saw you there.
Yeah,
I ran into,
I saw you at the Improv and Steve Burton was there also.
This is what,
Saturday night?
Yeah.
And he's screaming drinks for all my friends or whatever.
Steve Byrne,
I have a lot of friends who have television shows like good friends of mine and
I've never been on them.
Steve is a guy I know he's a friend,
but not like a really good friend.
That Saturday night you were plastered and then you left and then I was talking
to him and he's,
when he leave in town,
I'm like,
Wednesday.
He goes,
oh,
that's great.
We tape on Tuesdays and there's a role that will be perfect for you.
He goes,
you got a second.
Pulls out his phone,
calls it as executive producer,
gets off the phone.
He goes,
we rehearsed Monday and a film Tuesday and the role I went by there first that
night.
Well,
the role was a part of a road comic that sucks his cock.
It's a very complicated piece.
Back to the front desk guy blowing.
You're from Missouri.
Jesus Christ,
I could've had my teeth removed,
does and seen.
This is the end,
this fun.
We ran out and buy three hours.
We did it.
We did a 500 podcast.
This is wow.
500 gentlemen.
It was a part of the 500th.
You ever done it?
500 times.
Three hours.
Cause it's to see what that is.
I don't think it really is three hours.
I think a lot of them are too,
but there's most of them are three.
The majority of them probably like 80% since the end.
This is the end.
Oh lightly frank.
Where are you going to bitch?
Asia.
How dare you when Asia for a month.
How dare your Tom Rhodes.
I'm going to Hawaii.
Maybe it will be on the same flight.
That makes sense.
The same direction now over in Honolulu,
we're going to Hawaii.
You doing gigs now?
Mileage grab.
I needed to,
I met a front desk.
I go through Hawaii and uh,
I go,
I just tweeted,
hey,
I'm going to Hawaii.
Set me up with a Gig.
Anyone.
And within like I think 12 hours it was done.
Wow.
Well,
so I tried it again with the,
I didn't actually tweet it this time.
I went back to the same guy.
Well Eddie if does there that night we got,
they saw your council meeting.
So No,
I'm going to see Eddie EFT.
Hey,
here's my plug.
Why I have some dates coming up in Seattle and Portland and shit in June.
Go to my website but go see Eddie ift in Honolulu on Saturday night.
See me in Seoul,
Korea Saturday,
this Saturday coming up.
Yeah,
I don't know what that date is.
Well just Google it.
Make sure that Google it correct.
I'll be,
I'll be seeing Eddie gift.
There you go.
The audience.
Happy to be there.
Tom Rhodes is underscore Tom,
r h.
O.
D.
E.
S whoever the fuck this original Tom Rhodes is that.
Got It.
I Dunno.
I remember you told me once,
uh,
you know you go,
you shouldn't use underscore no one target to figure out where to find out the
score.
I had a hard time finding it.
I don't want anyone to follow me.
You can't find underscore.
I said that about both of you recently on a podcast.
Like why don't you have your fucking audience go after whoever has Tom Rhodes.
I mean,
not Joe rogan.com and fucking just assassinated until he gives up the websites.
And Nice old dude who happens to be older than me and he's been Joe Rogan longer
than I have,
but he cam,
he wanted to sell it to me.
You wanted to sell it to me,
but he wanted a lot of my,
I'm roads.com gave me Tom Rhodes.
Dot Net that's Korea.
Said.
All I had to do was give him free tickets for life whenever I played in Dallas.
That's actually a real estate guy in Dallas.
Real estate guy to,
mine's a real estate guy in Boise,
Idaho.
Kill the landlord's property,
talk property,
fuck property,
right for the Cape House,
except for the Cape House that only takes bitcoins demonic center once,
uh,
once we get the fucking raging bull to be the mayor,
give the foal rules changed.
That's it.
It's a,
this podcast is over.
This is the been the 500th one.
We,
uh,
we thank you very much for all of it.
It's been a,
it's ridiculous.
We started out in the living room just fucking around with a laptop.
And,
uh,
now it's
become something that's completely out of our hands.
It's,
it's,
it's on you guys as much as it is May.
Uh,
and uh,
I appreciate the fuck at all.
You and I can't say anything without sounding rehearsed and it's in insincere,
but uh,
I couldn't be a more honest about it.
Sounds so ting and legal.
Zoom to me.
Well,
legal zoom is next.
It's go to legal zoom.com Music Codeword Rogan,
save yourself some money.
Go to rogan.ting.com save 25 bucks.
Go to legal zoom and use the uh,
uh,
password norm,
500 episodes.
You dirty fucks a weed patch,
such a Wiki.
Very much joke that if anyone gets it,
I'll give you a free ticket.
Doug,
Stan hope plays in.
Gentlemen,
go to Doug Stan hope.com and leave your feces in Brown paper bag,
Van Dyke and [inaudible].
Got to go visit him.
He doesn't believe people visit him,
but people please visit.
I'm just once,
once in life,
follow a schedule,
fine.
Other days that are off.
Email him.
He'll email you back,
show up and bring beef jerky.
We love the fuck out of here.
We'll see you soon.
Bye Bye.
Much love.
You've got to have something to say.
Friday a,
it will be in Vegas with that Tony Hinchcliffe in Sarah Tiana.
Friday.
Vegas.
Go.
It's at a pool hall to bring Your Chalk Chalk.
There is a very slippery.